Loading, loading, almost there.
OK, I think I'm live.
Hello, Reflings.
Can you hear us?
Reflings, wake up, wake up.
OK, drama.
I heard that room.
Hello.
I'm waiting for Chad to respond, just thinking.
Oh, no, don't start puking.
Come on, it's a collab.
That's not how it works.
My puking.
Hello, Krishnamarka.
Good morning.
Yeah, OK, there we go.
Good evening.
Good afternoon.
Hi, Reflings.
Hello.
Good morning.
Do you want to see the artedorary for today's collab?
Shall I get these lovely girls to introduce themselves
uno by uno?
Right, starting from my POV.
Peaches, would you like to introduce yourself?
Hi, I am Peaches.
And I don't even know how to play this game, so yeah.
None of us know who you are.
Hank, would you like to introduce yourself?
Me?
Hello, I'm Baby Pink.
I also did not play this game, but I'll be Pink in the game,
so that's how you would know that's me.
I do ASMR, and that's it.
Hello.
Yay.
And then, last, but certainly not least.
Then, sister, who's Streamer, who never streams,
who just joined because he needed a filler?
What the fuck?
No, that's not how to play.
There's clearly a theme going on with this collaboration.
That's all I'm saying, OK?
There's clearly a fucking thing.
Like, we found out there's a colour red on this game.
They're like, oh, who's red?
I'll just get sinning.
No, that's how it is.
Get her in, guys.
So none of us, none of us have Castle Clashers experience.
Is that going to stop us?
No, so we're going to go in for the first time.
I mean, we might lose.
We're not going to mash buttons, you know?
The games, like, when you put up the games,
like, we recommend you use a controller.
And it's like, OK, I guess.
Geez, what's so complicated that a mouse and keyboard can't do it?
But, yeah.
You very wish us luck because this is going to go terrible.
We're going to introduce yourself as well, Strony.
Oh, hi.
I'm Strony Cuddles.
I am from Vealer, Gen 1, and Dulge.
I do do ASMR, but more on the Mimi side.
I'm not as serious as these lovely entourage with me normally do it.
So, yeah, thanks.
And, yeah, thank you.
That's my intro. Thank you.
I was like, yeah, yes, thank you, Colab.
I didn't know I was a streamer.
I used some artists, but no.
I feel like you produce such professional, high-quality stuff.
And in me, I'm like, here's thigh cupping for 15 minutes.
Take it or leave it.
I literally did a role-play where I was a toaster.
OK, real though.
And I was a vodka bottle.
Take my craft very seriously.
Thank you very much.
I haven't got a hypnosis ASMR.
We're convinced you'll like pineapple and pizza.
Oh, it's been advertised for that, baby cakes.
Oh, my God, the stream delay for me is terrible.
Oh, wow, I look so dumb.
I love it.
Oh, my gosh.
We're so cute.
We're in a tavern.
Oh, my magic is like, it's like hearts.
You're magic.
Oh, my God, rainbow.
Oh, I'm farting.
Man's literally far.
Hold on a minute.
Oh, yeah, I have to talk to these guys.
Peaches, is your thing working?
I'm just, well, I'm trying to use my controller,
and it's not working.
Hold on.
If I have to use mouse and keyboard,
then I'll use mouse and keyboard.
No.
I think I do.
It's OK.
I'm a pro gamer.
I can do this.
MLG pro.
Is everything a pro?
Ah, bitch, you made my melody, Bob.
We also discovered this game apparently has a remaster,
and we played the old versions.
That's how you know we appreciate
the older version of games, exactly.
It's not about the graphics.
It's about the soul of the game.
Why would they remaster this masterpiece?
Exactly.
OK, so.
It's OK.
I'm learning.
Left trigger is your shield, OK?
Not bad, not bad.
OK, Peaches is attacking.
We're getting somewhere.
Yeah.
I can't believe your controller broke.
That's so weird.
What's this?
A snail?
For fuck's sake, is it the one that you just
got from someone?
I have to buy you a new one now.
No, I think my controller's all right.
It's just I don't know why it's not working with this game.
Do you need to go to like send input controller?
I don't know.
Can I start?
Do you want to?
What do I put on?
Wait a minute.
You got what?
I was going to turn you off.
Oh, can you not hear me?
Oh, fuck, you said you're going to fart.
I thought.
No, in game, in game, my ability is farting.
It's stop.
My ability is farting.
My in game fucking ability is farting.
It's poison gas.
I was like, wait, what are you guys on about?
I'm actually going to fart in the make, bro.
Oh, I mean, you do you.
I just thought you were.
I thought you were a real streamer.
If you if you loved the reeflings,
you'd actually fart stronger.
They always do that.
You guys always trying to like a what's the word?
Gilt trip made a fart in the make.
I'm like, bro, refling.
I'll burp in your mouth, but I think I draw the line of farting.
All right, is everyone are we able to move an attack?
Um, yeah, I guess for the yeah.
You're going to have to carry me because I am shit.
I will carry you.
None of us.
No, I'll carry you with the power of friendship.
The power.
Yeah, actually, I didn't really.
How much did you pay?
OK, just to give you some a tiny bit back.
Sorry, pink was really disappointed.
She couldn't be pink.
She left the game and came back after buying the DLC to be pink.
Hey, it was only, I don't know.
It was like five is what it, which is one euro.
I guess one year worth it.
As she be read.
Thank you for the red she be.
Hi, hear him or Harlot's vice versa.
Oh, we've started already.
None of us have played this game.
So don't expect anything.
Not one thing.
Hey, I played this far.
You got.
Wait, the king's up there.
He's telling us to go attack.
OK, OK.
There's a lot of dead people around.
When did the fight start?
I'm just farting as soon as I see someone.
Oh, no, those are all those are the enemies.
That's a brilliant skill.
I can't fucking.
Uh, how can I think I might need to make us a bit slower on this?
A smaller on the screen.
I think I'm covering up like all the gameplay.
Holy crap. Sorry.
Oh, yes, you get you guys go.
You just keep fighting ahead.
OK, you guys keep doing your feet.
Sorry, you're doing great.
Keep up that one.
You didn't think you didn't actually have to do that, too.
Yeah, I mean, I was literally looking at you.
Oh, I'm not in game.
You're like the money.
I'm your money.
I actually like you.
Right, OK.
It's not very worse than I make it worse.
I'm just covering up chat now.
I feel really bad.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
OK.
What was that?
I like that.
I don't know what it was, but.
OK, I'm ready.
I'm ready when you guys are.
OK, yeah, I'm back.
I think this is better.
It's fine.
Yeah.
I'm foreign.
I'm a poison damage them.
Actually, this kind of reminds me of
if you guys ever played in South Park, the stick of truth.
No, I've only watched it.
I only watched it.
I don't know why the combat is kind of reminded me of it.
Did we share?
No, there is the money here.
Oh, you got it.
Oh, my gosh.
We must save the princess.
Oh, my God.
Did you voice that princess meal?
What was it like working on the death team?
What was it like?
It was I earned for my DLC for pink.
Oh, that's how you.
Yeah, it was that voice line, the one voice line.
We're spamming, we're spamming.
Oh, my God, they won't die.
I'm not sure.
Give it a rest, buddy.
I'm not doing anything.
As long as you're spamming the bullets, the bullets,
there's no guns in this game.
So we just spamming the sword.
I'll be spamming the rainbow.
Literally, I'm far and all over.
I'm getting that poison damage in.
I just have a fork.
I don't I don't do I have a lightning ability.
I don't know I use if you're on keyboard.
I don't know what your special ultimate would be,
but I think you might be the lightning one.
Oh, well, that's useful.
Electrifying.
Have a look.
We must protect beaches.
She's the new princess.
Protect me.
I'm trying to find out why I'm special.
Well, you have to do the sound.
Yeah, you have to do that.
The princess being taken away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Mario.
Don't come.
You see that meme where it's like, dear Mario,
don't come to the castle.
I baked a cake and I completely fucked it up.
Don't come to the castle.
I love it so much.
Absolutely.
Oh, did you see that?
Did you see that video where peaches the whole version?
No, I don't think so.
Oh, God, there's like a video where the the peaches
is just giving it to everyone but Mario and Luigi.
Oh, what?
Wait, do you mean by giving it?
What do you mean?
She said, how?
I think I've seen that one personally.
No, I think you may be alone in this one.
I don't know what you're doing here.
No, it's so popular.
Wait, how does it go?
Chat, help.
How does it say?
Please help Mario.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, she said how?
I mean, I don't remember.
Oh, I didn't listen to it in a couple of days,
but I will subject it.
Oh, it saved me, Mario.
Oh, yeah, we're learning oh, yeah, yeah, Reflin said save me Mario must be that
That's not ancient
God I
Don't
How long is this is one of those talk of who I am
Literally, I'm green and I'm like spamming
Spamming I realize I'm the person that the wall looking at nothing. I'm like, oh, oh, yeah
We're helping
I'll let you I'm getting lost as well
As if green hasn't been my color for literal years
Strongly new combo a
We can
Oh, maybe you're on like a level that how could I have labeled up top?
You're doing stuff. It's the far. I'm telling you use your ultimate. I
Don't know what it is, but it's helping. It's a a such a combo. Oh, I'm yelling. I think it's pretty damaged
Yeah, there's no like friendly stabbing in this cuz you don't be dead
Oh, I'd be over it would be over before we wouldn't even get past the first mission
We'd be up. We would have to send each other in one by one if that was okay. There's an enemy. Oh, it is an enemy
It's a loot goblin
Back off fellow beast
Oh
Oh, they jump in me
What is this oh
I'm trying wait, why am I I'm like dancing on your corpse what the heck did you see that? Oh my god, I'll try and protect you
Oh, wow
Okay, we can like start spinning her I can spin my sword sword you cannot afford always try to raise them wait
Oh my god, he's giving them mech the most. Oh, oh, I want to save people
Okay, I think I'm gonna kill oh
What's your ultimate I
Think it's a I don't know whether it's my ultimate, but it makes me like foggy and
Maybe they can't hit you when you're like that. There is an ultimate. I
Are you just talking about the rainbow yours is rainbow means
Yeah, watch. Let me do mine. Look at look. Oh, yeah. Yeah, see and then one more one more move
Yeah, yeah, and then one more and then it'll do it. I don't know what you have to hit the one keyboard
But yeah, we can all
There's one more thing you can hit. Oh there. There. What would that do that again?
I just held it and it's that and then
Whatever my god a longer thing very nice. I look like a
Magic heavy is it heavy attack? Yeah. Yeah. They're heavy with heavy. Yes. Okay, uh,
Whoa, wait again again. Oh my god. Oh
You've got an ace call a stabby stabby are you okay?
Oh
Oh, oh wait, we're to take that down. We can
Yeah, it wasn't the Trojan thing. What is it the lame? What the fuck is that?
It is a Trojan horse, but it is a ram a ramming thingy mobile, but I'm getting
breath
Oh
No, wait, what have our lives?
This is terrible
This game honestly should be embarrassed to ever pick this collab. It was yeah, I would be
It was me. I picked this game. I thought it was a good club game, but it's like really hard
Oh my god, we died in the first boss battle
Please don't die in the first boss battle cry
Oh
The good touch
I think I'm very close to being dead and we are so done for
We are so done for
For
I really need to kill myself. Uh, what what the fuck do we get that they're healing?
Oh my god, nothing on your bumper stick
You press the little cup like a little healing thing potion. Yeah, but I don't have the potion. Oh shit
I got given one at the start of the game
Oh my god
Oh my god, we can't even without out. I'm trying bro the lag the lag
Someone please think of the lag for me and my ping is like a billion right now. I'm trying so hard to like
Spam my freaking poison
I don't know. Oh my god, the ping is so terrible
We're not even got it down to half health. I don't know how
I hate it. Oh
Do you heal? I don't I don't know. I feel like your rainbow thing should heal by the look
It's just visually visually
It's kind of
Spam double jump. I'm doubled. Yeah. I'm double jumping at the thing as well
Is this what we're supposed to do? This doesn't seem right
This doesn't
I mean, we need to buy something because we have money so I think we have to buy heels
Can't just swap the healer class. I mean, we're almost halfway on the machine thing now
Yeah, oh my gosh. Oh, we're actually doing something to it
Yeah, that's all we need is a wee bit a cheeky chip damage like a cheeky chip
Bro someone liked the comment and they were like you sound like you run a fish and chip shop and I'm like, thank you
I don't even know what to take from that
How many times I die now
We'll get you here. We'll we'll pay for heels. Where am I? I literally cannot see me go
I'm like jumping behind the thing swinging. There we go. There we go
We're almost we're almost there
Oh, oh, I have
Thank you. I'm a nurse. I'm a field medic. I promise. Okay. No, I'm on the floor. That's what I'm
Okay, I'm open. I'm spinning. I'm spinning to win. No, I'm not I'm over here because I'm looking at sin
I'm not sin. I'm not sin. I'm green. I'm green. You're green
I'm literally going half. I'm like, I'm helping. I'm helping. I'm literally cutting the ear halfway down the map doing absolutely nothing from
You leave those molecules alone. I know
I could feel the oral I wiped up. That's nothing. I hate it
I know. Yeah, I know he doesn't but just the way it looks. Oh, oh you're leveled up
Oh
Oh my god
Now I can spin in a way all around I'll raise I'll raise I'll raise I'll raise if the game will register that I'm
Look at me spinning. Yes, but I'm all spinning. Oh, okay. Never mind. I'm official. Wait. Did peaches actually die die?
Can I not raise her?
There's no why above peaches
It's over
It's over the dream run is over. There's the world record will not be obtained by us
There's no way
Hello
Hello. Oh, oh my god. We've almost got it though. We've almost got it
Oh my god spam it spam it. We're it. We're red peaches because she'll come back in after this spam spam spam spam
Yes, oh my god, you done it
Oh
Oh my god, and what do we just mourn over your body? No, right? I'm not going anywhere without you peachy
Very do we have to like drag? Oh, oh, oh, oh wait
Oh my god, you touched my boobies and now I'm back
I bashed them the right way. That's what it was. You did and brought me back to life
I couldn't do it with my manhands. It was letting me
Oh my god
Wayne
I can't believe we lost the boss loot because we didn't pick it up
video game hate
I have to say if you kill if you do a boss fight and then the loot like treasures will randomly disappear
Sorry, but uh hate developer hate because that's just really
I don't I don't see why you need to time it like I've just done this boss battle. Please give me a chance to pick up
Yeah, like the gold is
Literally if it's a actual gold coin, why would it randomly disappear?
I don't get it. We did not just sit on the floor. Is there like soil falling from the sky to cover it up that can't get it anymore
I'm chopping the fence chopping bits of wood up instead of actually trying to you know kill the fucking
When you play minecraft, do you do look?
Do you do the caves or do you build a house?
I started to think you build houses then
Um, I don't yeah, I'm I'm being in here from all
a little wooden house
And make in the mine swinging our pickaxe from side to side
That's like the first time I've seen a critical hit
Beat them up beat them up beat them up beat them up
I just hit my nun get fucking wrecked
Oh
I know the guys said something about my nun so I'm beating them up. Yeah. Oh, right. You leave my nun on
It's all about the respect
I've poisoned. I love poison damage. It's like the coolest thing in video games. I don't I don't care what anyone says
I'm biased towards poison down. I love I love the old
damage over time stuff
Yeah, what the fuck do I do?
I
Spread loving I see you heal us. Can you do a rainbow on me and see if my health goes up because I feel like
Oh, no, it's an attack. It is an attack. Yeah, that's another I don't know what those little ones do
Oh, I mean you're on the dev team so oh, we have to get you for the voice actress
Oh
Did we get at least one princess by the end of the stream is my question
Or is that not how the game works is like I need more than one
I love you
Oh, that's what hard to work
On her I forgot to say by the way, I won't ask for more than two hours for the collab. I always I forgot to mention that
I
Never asked more than two hours because of the one anyone to be like, oh my god. I have to play for so long
But if any of you guys play valorous, let me move for no particular reason
Those are the princesses
You play valorous
Yeah, I'm obsessed
I play it all day every day. I'm
How excited you got
I'll win. I want to play valorant for the first time with like v-tubers that have already got experience. So
I'm so experienced. Let me care
Are you what rank through you? I don't even know how to rank through you. It doesn't work
That that's not important. What is important is I wait you don't play come wait. You don't play come
Or I mean, I mean, okay. I'm like I'm bronze to you right now, but I I was
I was like silver too. Okay
Okay, no
Whoever makes you happy. That's the main. Who do you play? I'm not really very familiar with the character name
Uh, I like the sentinel role. I play like cypher sage. I play vice at the minute the new one
There's a new hey, I played like three times with beaches. So I'm uh, um, are you MLG too?
I'm just playing the the russian character. What the fuck? I know there's another is a scottish
a character that came in
But she has the most
Default accent zacked into the ground with the fuck. Yeah. Yeah. He'll wall up. I can't raise peaches
Okay, oh
Leave me alone. I need raise. Are you raised? I'm raising. Thank you. Oh, no. I'm dead. Okay. It's okay. Go on without me
I'm in the corner, but that thing's gonna attack you that other one
That princess say help me
Oh, I just walked right into that. You did not see that. I just walked right into that. Oh my god
Oh, there's a banana
I need to know where I am. I've lost. Yeah, I can't see you think I'm dead. Oh, you're in the ground pink. We'll see if I say there you go
sake
Oh my god
Wait, I'm double jumping. I'm double jumping and twisting. Oh, no. I'm down as well
Oh my god, it's up to sin. No pressure, but it's up to sin
It's up to you. Oh, it's up to you baby girl
Oh
Go away. It's up to you. Oh, come on. Oh my god, you got slapped. Come on. You can do it. Oh, no
I'm fucked. Ah now you got this dodge dodge the
Second phase third phase
Heart of a millennia by the way. Oh my god. You're doing some good
Oh, look at those dodges. Oh, I might have been in the damage. Oh, you could be raised
You could raise pink at the left side if you wanted
Hey, what's going on? Oh
Hey, what? Oh, wait
Am I good? I got interrupted. You have not used all your skill points. Are you sure you want to continue?
Do we? No, we what?
Do we have a choice?
Oh, you oh, it's you putting in. Oh, it's peaches putting in. All right. Okay. Okay. Oh, okay. Oh, right. So
Should I just do one in each?
Yeah
Agility speed and archery. Oh archery. She got style one
Uh, well, this is your character. This is my point. Oh, I think once you select once you select your speeches, it'll go to us. I think
Oh, great. I'm not gonna do strength. I'm gonna do far
Yeah, the correct approach. Oh, I got new magic Richard
And pink is your tank. Okay. Oh
Agility magic or strength. I assume you just hit harder. No, no, no
What use the act like use like the the arrow keys or
Yeah, oh
I want to be oh, that's it. That's it. Just that. Okay. Well, that's you
You're like damn, that's all the xp I got
Oh vargum for uh, the fucking strength. So change your personas carefully. Oh, sorry
She got like a like a lucky dip there like a bowl of paper like what this persona we're gonna use today
Ah
I don't know why it was talking about me. How do you go name Jesus? Wait until you
Oh
Right, excuse me
Excuse me back to the very serious back since sister. Yes, sorry. I can't wait for your next name
I wonder what it's gonna be
Same I wonder if it's already
Come up everyone's chat. Come up in your name for me. Yep, Stephanie
Stephanie
I don't know
I don't even know Stephanie if I had to name you need you need a you need a hag name like
My real name
Uh
What's it? Uh, what's an old lady name?
And Helga, that's a hag name Helga
All hug us in the chat right now. I'm sorry Helga's right the one Helga being like damn. What did that do to you guys?
Like seriously
Mm-hmm
Oh my gosh, these guys are so right. We're doing way better. That's the good news. We're doing like so much better this time
Yeah, no, I'm dying. I'm dying. No, I'm dead. Oh, you're dead
Uh
I'm like spinning. I'm spinning. Oh, wow. I tried
Wait, you're both down. I died, right? Yeah, I ride the ride on the hold on
Let me get rid of this guy before trying right um can someone get me up, please
Why it's not registering my freaking trying to raise yours
It's literally not registering me trying to raise yours. Hello
I think oh, I just got absolutely rolled on
Right, I'm doing heavy attacks from now on those are like literally the best right if you raise them I'll
See this freaking is it's the lag input. Okay. I promise I'm an mlg gamer
It's the lag input
All right, yeah, you focus on resin. Oh, it's it's Karen a hagname
Well, yeah, actually because yeah, you don't really get young Karen's
Oh as I found the only one up right now CPR CPR CPR. Oh, no
I'm up. I'm up. Oh my god
This spot is curse
All right, are we seriously stuck and like this is the start of the game as well. This is what
Wait, how did I get two more points? I didn't do anything. You're just that good
All that bottom you did
Why am I trying to get like I'm going to focus now
Okay, I think we have to defeat that boss before we unlock further right. Let's go again
This time I'm like in talking anymore or giggling at the the desk. Okay, and this is
I'm fuming okay. I'm I'm gonna be serious. You killed all the elden ring bosses and we can't do this guy
I'm far and I can level one elden ring run back. I can't we can't fork
Eventually that was insane. I still can't believe you did that
And it's really fun
I'm spraying. I'm praying. I'm spraying. I'm jumping. I'm jumping. I'm jumping. I'm jumping. I'm getting away
He's looking at me. I've got aggro. I've got aggro. Okay. He's swapping. He's swapping. He's swapping
Go behind them and spank his fucking arse
I'm foreign
Polluting I'm polluting the environment. I'm out of there. Methane gas. Methane gas unleashed. Right. I'm in the ground
I'm in the ground. All right, get me up. Do some beans for harder
Beans make you far more you wait no no no what's that beans beans good for your heart the more you eat the more you fart
There's some british lore for you. Yeah
The the the more you something the better you feel so let's have beans for every meal. Yeah, I don't know that one
Oh, yeah. Oh, we're doing so good now
We are we're halfway. We're halfway. Okay aggro shift aggro shift aggro on send aggro on send
Everyone dodge good good on the back on the back. I have aggro green on aggro
Dealing with it dealing with the minions deal with the minions
Okay, there's pink is down. No, I ended right. I'm taking aggro way
Oh, you did it. You did it
Oh my game just broke
So it's not the good time it is time it is time it is hold on. Let me do it. How do we why did my game just
What the fuck
Grab the booty
Oh my god, we're looking by potions. No
Thank you for the 40 subs and bits. Oh get us up some bits get us up some bits. Wait. How do we cut her?
Oh, we got a princess. Oh my god. We got a princess
Oh
There was she's mine
Maiden
I think it didn't work
Oh my god, let's go
How do we kiss her? I think you don't can kiss her
Did she not look wait, whoa, she she's not very affectionate
Oh, what the hell wait, we're killing each other. What the fuck wait, is that why we suck so much
You just know
Yeah, you just killed me. How dare is you? I'm pressing why are you fighting for the princess now
Kill each other. Oh, we have to fight. Oh, fuck you. The princess is mine
No, no, let me far. Let me far. I'm far and get fucked get fucked get far down get far down
That was on the third get far down get far down. It's
It's gonna get me. No way
No way
No
69x oh my god, she's actually still kissing me a new character
It's me the Rizzler, honestly
No, I know that before I would have fucked right out of that castle
Oh, we're going on a pirate ship
I've heard these relics before we can set sail. Why would you ask them from us? Do we look like carpenters?
Do we have to explore?
It must be the other way there was like a northern route we could have taken I think are they in these barrels?
Is it in the seagull, excuse me, mr. Seagull, do you have a compass in your stomach? Are you just happy to see me?
Okay, I think we have to go back and then go to that other pathway. What was it up? Yeah. Yeah up. It looks like oh, yeah
Surely
straight to the battlefield again
Money
Whoa, I hate the goblins
I want the crocodile horrors
Whoa, I got the crocodile horrors. Oh my god
Wait, you've got a bow and arrow. Oh
Oh next princess we get to fight over
Oh, there's only four look like buttholes
Holy no, no, no, no, no
Wait, we're sure I want
Whoa, whoa, since we picked up since being pent manhandled since being manhandled
Oh my god, I love it
Oh my god, I'm getting hilarious. No my crocodile horrors. Is he getting stolen from you?
I think anyone can jump in you can you can jump on it too. I think
Ah
Oh, no
They can grab us
For oh, I'm down. Oh, I maybe went into the free a little too hard kind of looks like yoshi
Oh, no, fucking I killed this guy for the crocodile hose
Hell yeah
No
I
Do I want the I want the how do I?
Oh
Okay, all right. Oh, thank you. I'm coming. I'm cheeky red cp. Oh cp. Oh
Yeah
I used to be like ellie the elfin or something
You have to like if you're trying to raise someone you have to repeat the freeze to yourself like ellie the elephant ellie the elephant
really
I just learned that like honey club now
Oh, no, I learned it from like informational videos. I like looking at biology videos on
line. I'm a fucking weirdo. I don't know why
And it's like
You can like see like what the nhs put out about like how
I learned I learned that you can list you can uh sing staying alive from the office. That's what all I know
They change it often
I wonder if it is like to not make it a steal or something like when you're trying to save someone's life as if the adrenaline isn't pumping through your veins
Like oh, I gotta sing this again. I was like, uh
All right, come on. Come on wrap up wrap that health bar up
Oh
You got ambushed
I'm just farting into the void. I don't know what's going on behind here. Is this a dead end?
Am I dead? No, we just we just went too far too quickly. What? There's like a horse that just came out. Oh, I'm done again
What's an ambush?
Uh
Dead
Who picked a shape game?
Next time we're gonna valorant and be a lot easier than that. Yeah
Although with the pink difference, it'll be interesting
Me running around
Peach is level up
Yeah, uh, I want to be magic and
Just magic. No
Okay
Oh god, I'm I suck so much
No, you don't we're literally playing it for the first time
We're surviving. We're thriving. That's the main thing
Wait, oh, yeah, yeah, do the blacksmith go back to help what upgrade or stoof
This one. Yeah
Hi, can you make our weapons like
Oh
Yeah, oh
Oh, but I like my lollipop. Oh, no, I'm poor. It seems like it's somehow potion
Your lollipop gives you five plus agility. Thank oh my god, the broccoli
The broccoli
Oh my god
Oh, the broccoli is like super deaf
Wow
How do how do we buy this with that?
I think you just swap with x no
Oh, wait, no, you're on keyboard. Sorry
Um
I'm not sure whatever the attack button is like the basic attack button is apparently how you get it
Oh
Oh get bored
I'm putting it all in a match. Look at that. Oh, I couldn't afford this one somehow
I did dlc one because it's next to the lollipop, which was dlc
Well, I think I'm stuck with my whatever this is with cleaver. Yeah, just stay with your lollipop
Wait, so then how do we upgrade it? Do you not do it?
No, what the fuck's happening?
We're in the nurse's office. Oh, oh, it's a stable. Oh wait, this is like a shite over here
This is where you get pet, but I don't think there's any pet. Oh wait, there's a pet here. What is this? No, no, it looks like where your shit
Wait, why does it like me? Oh, why'd you pick me? Oh, I feel like that was for peaches
I'm not gonna lie. You touched him first. He's your problem now. Why does it why you following me bro?
No, my problem. Well, leave me alone. Leave me alone
Oh, he shits money
Okay, I'll have him. I want him back now. I'll be back. How did I give him to you?
Oh the one her
Yeah, maybe far on him and
I don't know. Oh my god. Okay. I don't think this will do anything. I think that I think he's yours. He's chosen you
He really said mommy
He's a weary flan. He said mommy instantly. I don't know how I did that
It does look like a whale
Yeah, a little worry boy
But you're cleaning after him
I'll gladly collect the poop
I guess we don't
Buy weapons upgrade this way. It must I don't think we are upgrading weapons. We're just getting new ones that that's it
You can just get new weapons and then it's just strength point
Okay, go. Yeah, go into the arena as well because we need to find the comfort stuff on the map
Oh, I'm so sorry. I didn't know what that meant
Oh, I've just put us in the fight. What what the what? Oh, no, wait. No, no. Oh, don't go to the edge. Don't go to the edge. There's cats
There's my pain
We're supposed to I'm sorry. I'm sorry. It's right. Right. I'm just attacked. Just attack me when it's over here
Yeah, just attack and get us out here because
We're not supposed to be in here
I was looking for because the compass was at the thingy randomly. I was like, oh, we can just
Um, explore like fine. Yeah, like find the rest of them, but I guess no
You know what? I'll let them fight
No, no, no, no
I wanted to wait to wait for you guys to kill yourself, but then the kitty killed me. We are now dead
So that's my right. Right. Okay. Let's not ever do that again. Uh
Let's all agree to never do it. Right. So the blacksmith we found the compass home castle. It wasn't there
It wasn't in the castle keep either. So what it's just up
We just have to go up or we can't progress across the water. Basically
Okie dokie let's fucking go
Surely we won't get ambushed this time
Absolutely
What's going on?
Oh, golden whale just like produces money for you. Yeah, yeah
That's why his little poopies are we're not mad at cleaning up. Oh, they took golden poopies
So then where do we buy?
We'll go back to that shop wherever it was
Even if we lose this one
And then we'll buy
Why have they taped her face but kept her
Susy buck
I'm level five. Oh, yeah
As I get my ass beat. Hell yeah, I'm level five
Got my magic spells done 17 damage when it hits
Don't mind if I do but I'm like there's so much visual clutter happening on screen
I'm like, oh, I've been picked up. Well, okay, I'll
No, let me go
Am I raising someone? Am I raising myself? I think I don't know something's happening. There's too much visual clones. Oh
Oh my gosh, we're are we supposed to be like leveled up before we come to this section or are we just not bad
I'm just the poison everywhere
Well, no take your guardian poop. Thank you
We'll go to the potion place that cup. Okay. It's an ambush. They come from front and behind
I'm just
Poisoning the heck out of them. Oh, I'm about to die because I hit my health. Ah
Okay, yeah, we'll pick up point potions for our health
And then holy shit, whoa
Whoa, that's what I'm saying. They're iris like so much. I I really I really want we really need to get
health potions from somewhere
Because we're supposed to have them with us and there is that shop back there. So we'll go
I'll piss off
Our savior
Fuck them up do it do it
Oh, yeah, right. Do not go to the right. Just do it. Get me up
Okay, I've got a 30 base health. That's good
I would do the CPR but my connection's so bad. I'm gonna like basically raise you with like one hp back
Okay, if you cut the grass sometimes fruit comes out of it and stuff
So don't be afraid to play lawnmower simulator
Oh, wait ambush ambush
Ambush, oh, oh fuck
Give me a here. Oh
I'm getting sunlogged by the bow and arrows
Wait, who just healed me somebody's got a thing to heal me or something
Oh
My god
Right, we'll go to that potion shop. It's definitely potion. So there's no way
There's no need to send we'll just kill everyone. Well, literally just
No, please
Oh
Okay
Are there so please
Pass off I came good then. Oh my god, please
Literally if you say yeah, if you stay on the floor the arrows are gonna get you so you're just like fuck
Forever doing
Okay, I mean you'll be you'll be leveling up really good with all this xp head
I think I forgot shielding at all to be honest you should
Someone says you should use your shield more. I'm like actually no
I'm doing all magic all the time, baby
They call her this since I'll get fucking nothing to it
Right, there is that potion shop wherever it was in the castle key
It might be yes. Okay. There is like a shop thing here. What is it? Yeah?
Uh
Bipsis
Oh
So how do we is this how we level up or no, it says I'm gonna take my shield strength down by one. Why would you do that?
I think I can buy for everyone. Can we could you?
Hmm, I don't understand why that would oh, I don't have any more money. Okay, so let me see if I can buy help
Oh, wait
I thought I thought I could buy for everyone
Okay, I'm only buying for myself right now. I have five potions. So I see my I have
I have deal
Did everyone buy
I think question mark
Right, let's fucking try again for the eighth day
Right, oh my god. Okay. That's how you defend. Okay. Now. I know
Okay left trigger. Yeah left. Um
It's left left down trigger
Whatever you're not doing keyboard
I
Figure I'll figure it out. It's fine. Maybe just just yeah, we can just wait for you to take an options
Yeah, there's no thing. So why that's an option to whatever the option of you. Oh, hold on one second
Uh block q it's q q
That'd be cute
All right, are we hurting each other? No, it's because we're
I
Give me the Yoshi
Get off
Ha
Right, we're ready. We're ready
Surely we won't mess this one up surely copy them
You see Aryan princess now
I have to cover right. I'm getting rid of these guys from behind
Okay, these arrow fucks us. We're god
Why am I am picked on I'm getting picked on right press B to heal
Wait, why is it not healing? No, it's doing a bone arrow. No heal
I'm up. No, I've been trolled. Wait, how'd I heal?
I've been
Oh, wait, wait, wait, it automatically uses your potion. Uh, if you go down, right, okay
So you can be a bit more aggressive than usual
I
I'm feeling my winged hussars all around. Okay, no no more
Why did it keep taking your
Okay, that was good visit me for more
Well, we wish we could please upgrade your weapon. Please peaches
Right shield shield
Commence with shield man
Two three four hut two three four
Okay
Yeah, I think they come behind as well. That's what's okay. So somehow I already used my potions. Oh good. They all up
Ah, it's the stun lock with the arrow hits. That's what's killing like absolutely throttling us
Again, you can cut grass for your snacks. Okay. No, that's the best method of healing but we can make it work. Okay, we can make it work
Okay, big ambush
big ambush
Oh, you got an animal
Oh
Wait, who's that? Is that my animal? Yeah. Yeah, you got it. You got it. What what does that? What does that poop out?
I don't I have no idea
Something uses your spoof subs money my poops like
I don't even know
It just burps. That's it. It doesn't do anything
That's actually pretty cool
Oh, right. I'm doing heavy attacks. This is too much
It's the stun lock in with the freaking arrows. That's just
Stop with the arrows. All right. I'm double jumping. I'm double jumping
Sprint what?
No, I'm double jumping. I'm double. I'm doing the sin method. I'm doing the sin method
I'm double jumping. I'm double jumping
Oh, I like the sprint
Oh my god, I'm double jumping
Right, the good news is we're doing a lot better this time
There's a lot more of us doing a lot better. Right, let's get oh, let's get pictures up though. Let's get pictures up. We'll miss our safe
I just don't want to raise you and then like I instantly go down. No, no, no, no. I know don't worry
I get to blame my ping on everything playing bad in a game ping
Doing terrible in a collab ping. Sorry. I couldn't hear you there. You're quite out
Really bad communication ping. Sorry. Oh, this kind of sounds like pink like I'm
Oh
We did it. We made it to the next location
Oh, whoa, what what did the bitch go? Wait, did we do we kill each other now? No, no the bush the bush. There's enemies in the bushes
Nice. Oh, well, this this music's good. I like this
Oh, sorry. I was oh, you're you're you're pet. You're pet swiss. You pink
Hmm
I didn't know it. Whoa
Whoa, he's got anxiety. He needs to I want this one. You want you want this shit in one?
Yeah, might doesn't do anything
I don't maybe it'd like boost your attack. Maybe or gives you higher agility
It won't take gunner
Um, oh the fuck is that in english?
I get her. You said the right word
Oh, I got you. I got you health pink. I got you health. Did you see that? Oh?
Yeah, I saw that like once fine. I guess you're doing something
But it's not like the golden whale that she's gold
I mean anyone can pick up the coins you guys can take I'm not
At least you have a pet
I know I still don't understand how it didn't lock up to you. I got some kind of weapon
Oh, we're unlocking weapons inside the wheel thing my barber. Oh, please
She got some kind of before and now I got one
Oh
Wait mine
Oh, it's mine. Okay. I like my pet now. Yeah, sorry if it's bringing you stuff. I name you. Um
Oh my god. Well, now I'm dead. Can't you fucking wears me pet?
On my screen that was correct. So if I'm giving you like terrible health, I'm blaming the like
Yeah, it's like
Oh, there's a deer. Thank you
Do you want to kill it though?
Why?
I don't know what I'm saying anymore
Why is everything
When is this like a curse wooden the curse woods of diarrhea is what we're in right now
Okay, oh, there's another pet another pet. There's a pet. There's a pet. Oh, oh, yeah
Oh, this this is the pet level clearly
Geez
Oh, I like the ground fee. I'm flying a sea course
Yeah
He's my baby
I'm dead
Oh my god, this OST is on we can't leave your pet for a mama. Let's get you back up
What will he do without you? Who's it gonna give snackies to
I'm just gonna clean this passion. Shut up
no one
That's a 200 dollar 200 quid fine. Wow. Whoa. I don't like this. See you. What the hell is this?
Are they res magic resistant? They better not be
Oh, they drop
Oh, I see you here. Oh, there's another weapon here. Uh, someone can get new one
There's one inside the temple here
I can see one watching us
I can creep
Are we about to get pranked and we're about to do a boss fight
My gamer senses are tingling. I don't like it. Why is it so hard to kill this one?
Hmm
Visit me for more
Nice. Well, someone can get this one if they wanted but
We don't really know the weapons anyway
Did we make it? No, there is a fake
Whoa, it's a snowberry
What?
Why does everyone shit in this game? What?
Is this a child game? Oh, wait, hold on a minute. Is this for babies?
Constipated bear
Yeah, invisible wall. Oh
We actually made it out
Give me me fucking back. I mean everyone's pissed in the shed. Me must be walking into something really cool
Surely the boss isn't gonna be
Like really no, it's not going to be themed after shitting and pissing
The water is just put the water is like a color on it and shit. That's why everyone's a color
You know, that's why they're pissing and shitting. It's not because of a scary fucking boss coming up or anything
I don't like this level. I'm sorry. Not the mirror. No, this is so hard
Oh
They have like a little village. Oh, we're pillaging the village. Oh, yay. Let's let's fucking destroy it
This is what you get for doing like being mean to us on our own
Well, you deserved it. I don't care what you're waiting. Wait, if they're running away from something, hold on a minute
Hold on a minute. If they're
Oh
There's a boss bar. There's a boss bar not to upset anyone. There's a boss bar. I don't know where it is
I'm spamming right side. I'm spamming right side. That's all I'm doing. Oh, I'm getting an eyelid. I'm getting an eyelid
I am jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump jump
Spin attack spin attack. Oh, I'm on fire now. I'm on fire now
Oh my god, there's like so many wee guys on the ground
No, no, no, why am I fucking dead again?
I think everyone's out of potions now
Why'd they make this so hard? We better have like a billion levels up after this game. I'm not even like after this level
There's everyone on you now. Okay
Oh, I made it now. Oh, yeah
Whoa
How are we supposed to win any of this? I'm getting stun locked. I literally getting stun locked
I'm getting I mean you're level seven. I'm level four still
Bruh
They just didn't stop
I need to try and cast some freaking magic because that's my best attack. It's my best attack. I have magic and that's it
Oh
There's no way these we oh my god. He just keeps coming out. We're more of them
How am I supposed to raise?
How am I supposed to lose?
He just keeps coming and coming and coming and coming and coming
Surely
I'm uses just I mean at least these guys are melee and then like most respectful way at least are melee
But yeah
Because if they were arrows, we'd be done for
Yeah
Please just so many of them
Please I'm trying to raise
Okay, I got one raise pinks up
That's the best I can do. Oh, I'm up. Oh, oh, oh, I'm down. Shit. Oh
Okay, I better rescue
Okay, I'm carrying a literally sin carry
This is impulsive. I'm down again. I'm down again
I sin I sin on our own
I mean we got less than 50. We did 50. That's not bad
More points in the defense. I think so
Yeah, spin spin get all the eggs key for the level spin to win spin to win
Let's say I'm getting gameplay spamming the same button over and over again. Oh, so riveting so exciting to watch
Oh, NLG put work
Learn from this
Oh
Yeah, you're doing it. Look how much health she has
What you're fucking killing it. How are you doing this?
Yeah, I'm doing what you're doing. Don't go in the fire though, but keep doing what you're doing because
Oh, you're leveled up new combo x y
Oh, no, no, just jump just jump just jump you're getting some look just don't listen how thin that. Oh my god. That's dangerous. That's dangerous
Oh
Show us what them gamer fingers can do
Carrie sin
So that's how you play the game. Okay, let this right there
Just jump
Think she keeps eating cherries off the ground
Uh, yeah
I think they're oh my god. They just keep spawning one or more
Is this like infinite level up kinds of maps because I feel like once you're over
What's going on?
I have no idea if I got caught on something
infinite xp
Glitch yeah, honestly, I feel like that's like a level up map like yeah, I use that to level up
Right, and then I guess I'll put in defense. Uh pressure got to me. They got to me. Okay
I'm putting in defense so we can stay up longer. Uh
Can't believe it. I need to put some in there. I love that strength. I love that magic. Jesus Christ. You got so many
I'm just abandoning the last one. Oh my god. So you need to rename yourself spin sister
Honestly, let's switch into my favorite
Oh
Did we just go again or do we like farm on ones that we've already done before there since
I just want to buy more potions. Can we go back to potion? Oh, yeah
And we just heels good call a castle keep that was a castle keep
Can I really not buy heels for other people? Is that not a thing in this game?
It does seem like a very like hey, this is a really common thing. Shouldn't this be implemented
Smile, maybe this seems a freaking master
So we're complaining
Oh, honestly, it probably will be as well. Let me go now. It's all in the remaster
Right, I think five potions is enough, you know, are we all happy we're a potion gathering how many do you have?
Oh, that's enough
truly five
Don't watch the flex or anything. You know my five potions
Mm-hmm, right at least we're leveling up like even though we lose and like the thing
We're still getting the xp and the level up for it. So I'm not too like
Oh, I'm region
You know
I'm spinning I'm spinning I'm spinning. Well, actually everyone just fucking spin it when spin only matter
Oh my god, we've already phoned out the middle
Shield and spin shield and a blade. Oh the shit. Oh, wait. Let's do the way. Why did he do that? But why?
Is it because he's scared of the boss?
He's terrified. I just realized it's he's not actually coming. It's it's the bird poop
You saw the
Yeah, the brain rock has got to pink the brain rock has officially hit. Do you do you know how birds have sex?
They just rubbed their butts together
Whoa
Honestly, that sounds pretty cute
That's the milliest that's the milliest thing I ever heard
Let's rub our butts together
Butt rubbing uh
VTuber convention one
Uh, I'm down
I'm on you. You know weapon
Break
Oh my gosh
It's not enough to have your shield out. You must be facing the same way the arrow comes out. I can't believe it
I can't believe I can't just cheese this game
Whoa, I haven't I haven't I haven't maled it. What what is it's when?
I think you just picked up there was another location. Oh, no, no, no again. Not again
Oh
I wish we had flowers like this
New character unlocked and he's just brown
Right, your fish is lodey. They keep dropping coins. Where's the girls?
Bruh, I don't know. I think he just like breathes oxygen and turns it into
Oh
That covers up so much of the screen that notification
Yeah
Oh
That's mine already has that. Wait, I dropped my sword. Give me a bag. This is my sword. Give me the sword. Okay. Oh, okay
No, no, no, no, you never took it from me. Wait
What?
I pressed eggs. Okay, then swap
I could have had a bang in sword then
So we could have done treesies
But now we have the
I can swing my sword. I guess this is a hammer
I want more creeps creep fight me
Oh
Hmm
Bruh, they have so much hp as well
Or is this no, I guess it's like a zombie
Maybe
No, I don't want the stick give me the mallet. Thank you. I don't want to
Wait, I'm stuck. I'm stuck. You need to come back. I'm sorry
I
Wait, why is this thing wrapped up? Give me the mallet. Hmm
Or is this like a hidden thing?
It makes my strength go down but makes my magic go up. Hold on a minute and boost my magic up
That's all I care about. Hey, wait, I'm like stop go around. Thank you. Jesus
Game's so rude
Oh
Not again. Uh, no again
Yes, again
Oh, no, you can see it come up his face and everything. That was a violent one
Oh my god, that's me after I ate soy honestly
Just shut up your back
I mean, yeah
and I was
And I started being allergic to soy like recently and I guess where soy is in
Everything. Yeah
Especially Asian foods
Oh, is that like your favorite food type?
Pretty much. Oh, no, I would
I really like Mexican food and I have that thing where is it like cilantro tastes like soap
Oh
Yeah, many people like cilantro. I don't really mind it
Okay, okay, no one go in the fire. Let's keep our HP as high as possible
Okay, they're running away from the boss, but we're gonna farm them for xp because they should have thought about it before the attack does
Okay, I'm not good. Not going to the fire. You say no fire fire bed. Okay fire bed
I'm gonna bun go fire bed. Well, it's good. Let's keep this one. Wait. Where's the boss?
Oh, I spoke too soon. Right. He's coming. All right. I'm spamming. I'm spamming. I'm spamming. I'm spamming. I'm spamming
Oh
Spamming your magic on him
Spamming magic
Magic
Oh gosh, please
So they can go on fire if you want to try and
Utilize it
Let's stop with the thing
Jump meta jump meta
Pink level up pink level up jump meta
I'm doing the the sin strategy. It literally is working. It's working. It's working so well
That was our problem whole time
I can't believe you've burst the meta. If it's okay, I'll take it's really
I'm gonna make a youtube video right now about this new meta, you know
How old is this game? Is this like a
They can't like try to tell her something
Never too late for a meta, you know
literally
Ah, I need to hit poison
Because it's doing so much tick damage on him. It's so good
Oh, there's so many of the baddies
Buddy over here
Please do not sunlock me. I'm trying so hard to win right now. I'm trying so hard
Okay, it seems like I hate to admit it. I hate to admit it
But I think I'm investing in the defense might have helped. I hate to admit it, but
I literally never touched the
Oh, I oh you mean the stats. Yeah. Yeah, like when we leveled up the we'd put some into defense and never like that was easy
Yeah, that was like chat was tried
Chat was right once again. I can't believe it
We did it. Wait, what are they all running for? Oh, I I don't know. Oh
There's more wait that wasn't it. We've not finished the level
Oh
Oh my gosh
Oh my god, I'm on a deer. I'm on a deer. I'm on a deer. I'm off
Oh, I want to do that the poops jump jump jump keep jumping keep jumping jump jump jump jump jump
Just spammy spammy
Oh spammy surely. It'll be fine. Copy him. Just keep spamming. Just keep spamming
I'm not okay. Oh my god. So we can do the poopy sprint. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
Oh, I go ahead
Do you guys still have potions?
Yeah, yeah, I just I just use one. Okay. Oh
How are we supposed to know come on? How are we supposed to see the doorway?
Yeah, how are we supposed to see it? That's not enough time for me every act. That feels that feels random on them
I cannot anticipate the road ahead. Okay. Yeah
Like as long as one of us makes it to the end we win
As long as one of us makes it to the end we win surely this sequence wait, are we supposed to be attacking him or something? No
Bruh, these walls
Oh my god, wait the light on the floor
The light on the floor the light on the floor
That's the best I can do
Is the light on the floor for the doorway and then there's the jumps of course to make it nice and awkward
Oh
Okay, okay, okay
We did it we're safe. We had to be pink behind
Pink Spain she was just taking a nap
I'm on a fish now. I was just chilling here
Ow. Oh my god, the rock's not cute
I want to be on a fish
Apparently you're supposed to stay in the middle. Oh my god. I'm getting beat up. I'm getting beat up
I don't know by what I'm spend matter spend it win spend it win
It keeps us out of the water long enough. How did we end up here? Oh, you can get on a log
Oh
Wait
Okay, I picked up something. Oh
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. No, I just got knocked off. Oh, but how are we supposed to right spin spin?
What the hell is this?
Oh my gosh, I know but it doesn't
There's no way we're supposed to actually win at this rate
I can't even jump on something right
Do not knock me off. I had to go fast boy
Bruh the rocks that knock you off. I can't even do any spell casting
Oh my god, I'm just getting knocked off more. Okay. Can we only jump?
Yep, the best I can do is literally spin on his arse
Doing a 360
No scope. We can't even kill it like he doesn't have any
All right, the best I can ride the show
Oh, right. I'm I got some poison on. I'm geez
No, there's another one go away
Okay, so it can be killed what we don't he don't don't see hp level that's why it was confused lovely mystery
hp bar and i'm low health
How
I wish you could pick a level and then be like do you want to play easy mode? Yes. I want to play easy mode. Thank you
I
Just got knocked off. What mode are we playing there? There's only one d4 like so. Yeah, there's only one
Ah sin got the fish
Oh
I wish you had a pet
Okay, spam in the poison and then I get knocked off instantly as soon as I get on a platform
You're so strong. You don't need a pet
I'll let you know jupo, but you will get it eventually
Eventually and then to be like the most powerful one. Yeah, you'll have the best
Yeah, I get unicorn pet
Poison poison no, and then I get knocked off instantly by the rock. I don't know who designed this level
This is
This is awful
I don't know what our goal is we're to kill the damn frog thing and obviously my best damage is
When I'm on a platform
and off it's teaching
Literally all we can do
And I've got two potions that are about to get freaking wasted on this fight because it the rocks keep knocking me off
So I can't even do any magic
Get me on the fucking crocodile
Oh, please no more another one's gonna
Wrap it up wrap it up
Wrap it up
Wrap it up. We've had enough of this level and there's a back
Oh, and I'm off the platform again. So I can't do anything. It's supposed to be easy to frog
A spiky frog. I can't use this. I hate that sound he makes
And I'm not
I'm not
I can do 10 damage with magic and then I instantly get fucking knocked off so I can't
Right now it makes me burp
She's fuming
Bruh
I like let me be on the and then it's like as soon as I get on it
It's like oh, here's a rock to knock you off it. It was like, okay. Thanks. I didn't want to use any of my magic
Remember that dog fish you put in the game that big ass mechanic where
What the fuck
Oh, it's the king
The king came to help us
Oh, oh my god. No, we don't have there's we don't have the team for a freaking boss battle. Are you kidding us?
Oh, I just got walloped. I just that's a catfish clearly. Oh, yeah. Oh my god. Yeah
Uh, where am I? I can't I can't
Why did that kind of look like can you use the cannonball?
Oh, it's like so much that we can help them
I know
I I can play so am I too dumb guys my point is nothing
Ow
Bruh, this is all in one level by the way like
It goes on forever. I think we're gonna have to farm on other things to level up before we freaking do this guy
One damage by the way
One damage, I guess I need to put it in defense so my melee's more effective because this is like
Pishwa capital ish
Why is it the cannonball perfectly hits the frog but as soon as it comes to the big massive hitbox target
All of a sudden the king canny day pish
That's a little excessive
Like I feel like this is target. He doesn't want us to get the princesses because it doesn't like his doors
Just admit it. You didn't like your door
Oh, the king has a shield
Oh, I forgot about that shield. Can you even use no, you can't use a shield on the water. No, you can't
Oh, that sucks so much in the water
Yeah, I take that
I'm not even doing poison damage
Bro, I'm useless. I'm actually useless this fight completely and wholeheartedly useless
You're alive. That's that's useful. Yeah
Me and pink are the true useless
No, no, no, it's because I've managed a bit
I'm a fraud. I'm a fraud. It's because my a pet gives me money for more potions so I can stay up for longer
I'm a fraud
You found out my secret. I thought you were just a mega gamer girl
I can't believe you had to find out this way. I'm a bad
I'm a lot broken
Oh, come on. It's thin on the other hand. I don't know how you have so much like
You just don't die
She's the original
I'm just
I don't
Like
Okay, so I'm not paying my taxes to the kingdom after this if this is how my cannonballs are going down
Are you joking like they wonder so much about this
No, don't give up and look at the king. He's he's just screaming and covering himself
I didn't even helping or if he's you're like
I think this is just screaming at you guys a fake boss fight honestly
I'm gonna sit back and let's try to spin it. No, I'm trying to spam
Out wait as furballs
His furballs drop help hit the boat and then the bomb fell fell down. Oh, can I get on the shark? No something like that
It's something like
I'm farting. Okay. There we go. I'm doing nine damage
Oh, wait. What now you can nine whole damage
Like yeah, sure
Somehow his bomb went further to the cap right totally right does that have it works?
Uh, no, it seems I why would I
Bro, I leveled up and I got fully healed. I want to go down
The king show you amen. Get a grip. He's aimbot something actually install aimbot on his fucking boat. Sorry. This is just
This is no macking
No
Honestly
Please far
Don't kill the football when he's closer. Wait, what did that do? Oh my god. What did you do? You did something? I can't see myself
Um, I'm trying to hit on the nothing's registered. Oh, okay. Of course it registers when I'm not paying it
Give me a log right there. Where's the fucking log?
Bro, I've got a log broon if you want one
I'd have fucking
Purple purple right, what do I do?
Oh my god
Not as fucking understanding the mechanic like eight years too late
Oh my god, right. Oh my god. We're beating him up. We're actually doing it. Oh god
They're actually going to do it. I don't know I'm button mashing so hard right now. I'm button mashing so hard right now
Right jump feet. Oh no, he's got a new face. He's got a new face. He's got a new face
I don't know what the face is. I don't know. I'm jumping. I'm doing the I'm doing the sin spin
Sinsily shagged again shagged. Okay hairball hairball hairball hairball hairball breaking up breaking up broke it broke it broke it
Sun sun stagger
Saga
Please
No, I'm foreign. I'm foreign. Come on. Come on. Come on. Get so much poison
I'm poison. I'm poison. I'm poison
I'm rolling for perception check percept
I rolled a three. I rolled a three
This is awful
I don't die sin. I will don't make it up to me, right? I'm doing the farball. I'm doing the farball
All right, there we go farball sun sun sun head to sun head to sun head to sun
It's over. Head to sun. Head to sun. Wait, that didn't work
I don't know
I don't
I'm on HP. No
I'll leave it up to me
Okay, I got it. I got it. I got it. I got it. Wait that he missed he missed
Bro, we did what we were supposed to do
Is that like what 15% HP or something? Oh my god, it's over
No, no, no
Okay, farball farball farball farball beat it up beat it up beat it up. It won't break right and then stun lock him stun lock him
What are you doing?
What are you doing? I can't do something. I'm late. I thought the wolf was abusing you
Oh my god, get me on the wolf so I can get out of the way. I can't get on in it
You're ruining it
Who coded this? I want a word. I want a word. I want a word right farball. I'm gonna miss it
I'm gonna miss it. Right. I got the farball
No, wait go go
What are you doing? Why am I back? It's not registering anything. Are you fucking serious?
Do you know how long we've been waiting for that?
Are you freaking serious?
Why does it not register an attack if you hit an enemy on his back? Is he gonna be like sauce? No damage
No
We have to like line with the cat up
This is uh, I don't oh my god. Stop. Oh my god. I can't reach it at all. They will all they will shoot
Oh my god
Stop oh my god
You are
That was awful. That's the longest time it took anyone to do this stage for real
That was a road record for sure. I don't think anyone spent that line for time on that. No, holy shit. That was awful
That was amazing. That was amazing for us. I'm doing all magic. I'm doing all magic. That literally is the only reason why
Oh, okay. Um
That was terrible
Who made this game so hard? I need a word with the development team
I'm sure there's like something obvious. I'm scared to go into the next let's go back for potions. Fuck this. I'm going back. Wait, what?
Oh, dub dub dub. Just screaming at me that I have to leave the fence
There's like so many new areas on launch. Thieves forest is what we were in
Thieves store. We got more items. Oh
Hello, I don't even have money. I don't know why I'm excited. We have bumps
We have bombs. I just want two potions and that's it
I guess if we're not doing a boss fight just yeah, I won't buy a bomb. I'll buy hell
No, it's Bravo. He he he he. Hello. What what thieves have a store. What the fuck?
Okay, I have a bomb as well. I'm not really sure how to drop it, but we'll do it at some point
I want a bomb there girl
I feel like it should be fair to
steal from the thief store
honestly
Thieves charge more money for potions. Are you sick? Oh, do we just get skimals?
I think we wouldn't skimals. Do we need to go back to the pets
Section so you guys can read what your pets there or anything like that. Oh, yeah, maybe
Right, I'll take us back to the little no not that way down down left left left left left
Left not that one
Not that one home castle
Why no wrong one one
Wrong one. Wait, it wasn't home castle. What one is it with the lady?
Oh, no, it was that the wait. Why is there what?
Ah, this is just the first map
Oh, I'm an idiot
Sorry, I just made us replay an old mission. Sorry
Sorry, right. It was the blacksmith. That was it. It was left of the blacks like we go in the blacksmith
Oh, can't wait can't wait. Oh, okay
Oh my god, I did powerful. Oh my god
Let's get one shot in
Oh my god, the magic actually
As long as my magic hits. I'm actually not useless for the team club club club
As long as it hits though. Yeah, I'm just gonna spin in the corner. I just want a pet
That's what I want. That's my pet because seahorse a fish. That's my favorite scene
I can exit to map if you guys don't want to play this
Yeah, we can exit. Okay, hold on
Are you sure? Yes
Okay, blacksmith and then left is the animal body
Okay, here you go
That's about the power
I will let retrieves hidden fruit from trees. The golden whale earns you more. No shit
Oh, you mean this whale that drops gold it drops gold. Oh, okay. Got you. What about the weapon lady?
Seahorse lets you move. Maybe that's not the one that I think through water quickly. Oh my god, wait
I'm so sorry. What do we want here?
Peach is so such a
Okay. Oh, yeah. What does what does the seahorse this makes her move through water quickly? That's it. It's a jelly
Nothing else
You're drowned quickly
I don't wait been a pet. Oh, no, I just lost my pet. Oh, well, do you want to wait you want to
He goes if you don't if you go near the bend your pet will unfollow you and he's away over here
Right. Okay. You have the pet. You have the pet. There you go. I just want a pet
Wait, is that a more further down? Is that what it is? Yeah, that's the only one only a fish
Is that a whale? Oh, yeah, only a whale. All right. I'm out. Oh, he dropped money
He drops my touch him and he'll come with you
That's enough to stash him three two one
Oh
Come on. Good. He doesn't like to be touched anymore. He doesn't like what?
Does he only
Wait, what?
They have a preference. It's then
I see. Oh, okay
Get some petless maiden lives. What else pets have
I think their character locked pets. Oh
All right, so
Oh, there were weapons. Oh, I don't even have money. We did have more choices
Choices
There's like a weird middle. Oh
Whoa, it keeps going
Masi would like these ones. Oh, that's defense
Oh, I want this look
Why not? I have defense now
Yeah, nice. Those are defendables. Yeah, maybe I won't die so fast. No
Oh
I like your pose when you do that. You like stick your finger out pink. Yeah. Oh, you just be sane
I'm just like, yeah far
Come on. What was yours again?
Your ultimate
Like your oh
That's making cold not the red ranger
Of course
Right, let us right. So we went to look at one. So we've not done the abandoned mill. Wow. Look at that one there
I wonder if there's a boss in that next there. Oh wait, we did just do the abandoned mill. Did we not?
I'm so confused. Oh
Oh, we did all of this in a row. Oh, I kept putting us through missions
I thought that was one big long ass mission
It kept making us go next I guess
So this is the next level
Yeah, the king's let us off
Oh my god, I'm going straight to the fire
Beeline for it. Okay, so we need to get ready for it. Is that flag like a cute little pole?
Yeah, it does
Visit me for more weapons and scissors. Does anyone I know it's less magic. I like not
I'll take my chances. I'll take my chances. Oh for some reason my scissors give me defense
Oh, that's so cute. Oh one just rolled dead even more
Uh, oh my god. Yeah a little bit. It's like mr. Cuddle's cousin
Man, they take a hammer and 24 hit on the snot and they still aren't dying
I
Can't believe we're fighting the snowberries. I see don't look. I'm sorry
Let what
We're fighting daddus
We're literally the daddus are coming. Oh, no. Oh, I don't know if you guys had that book
Yeah
Oh
And eat back off
Right, I need to I need to play this at a major's range if I'm gonna literally spam down major because yeah, I'm gonna get in trouble
I can't see
I can't see there's so much visual clutter on screen and the bears are like leveling up as well
Oh, they're like bubbles. Yeah bubbles coming from them. They're taking bubble baths
We're taking bubble baths for
Uh
We seem okay in quotation marks
But yeah
Levelers
You get fully healed as well when you level up. It's really good. There's a
Oh, I love that. Oh that little do you see that little creature?
Oh
Oh my god, new pet. Oh my god. It's it's it's it's like a flag and spinning
You play league. Oh, no, I'm any end. I used to I'm sorry
Oh
But but do you like you like poison damage over time you'd look female
Oh, it says that wait. Is there a poison character now? Hold on. Yeah, what's the mushroom?
Hold on a minute
Oh, you have to play now. I'll I volunteer to play with you
I was going to see if Azura would do me an introduction stream because she loves it. Like she adores the legend
Um
But that's why I thought about the valorant thing as well
I was like, I'll never really played it. It'd be funnier if like vtubers like showed me how to play it type thing
And it could be like a fun to have I just feel like I'm going for it
I'm in and I'm being like getting flashbanged every screen because I know that apparently the games uh all the enemies and
Like can flash it a lot in
valorant and I was like I'll have my reactive model on so like I constantly get like flashbang
to
every two seconds
Are we supposed to be doing something about that hurricane?
Oh, it's a boss fight. Oh my god. I was too
Meanwhile, there's a boss in the background
Yeah
But don't worry. It's us since goddess
It'll actually send all just clutch up. It's fine. We don't have to do anything. Let her deal with us. No pressure. No pressure
There's you last game. It's at the narration
I was Kazama. Um
What is it called
My magic literally once he got stunned all of a sudden he was like super
like
In trouble. I'm level 12. No, that can't be right. There's no way I'm level 12. I miss Ruta
Are we checking exactly? I don't know
The the one that keeps going into a hurricane is the boss. He's constantly see he's got like an arm anymore
Oh, I'm out of freaking HP. Oh, because we tornadoing keeps getting me as well
Uh, oh god
I'm trying to poison him, but he's not taking no for a freaking answer. Rez Rez Rez
I'm trying to get off of her. No, no, no
Okay
I need to back off. He's coming for me
Okay, let's just spam snot down the main
No, that didn't work. I literally missed everything tihi. I missed everything
That was a waste
Where is he he's behind
I'm spamming if I could get poison damage. Oh poison. He's poisoned. That's all we need
All right, let me get over here
Oh my god, peaches can't catch a break this game. I don't are we all over?
Oh
I'm trying to get that up and it's
Constantly fighting the enemy instead. Nope. I would like to get sent up. Please. No, okay. No, okay. I guess I'll go
Oh, I have to get sent up. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, I can't sorry. I can't do it. My thing's not registering
Oh my god
No, no, no wait. Where am I? Is it me? Am I the problem?
No
Oh my god, hold on. Can I get more up? Can I get more up? Please register? Thank you. I don't even know what we do the boss
We just gotta keep
Ah, right. I'm trying. I'm trying. I'm trying
Thank you
Oh, oh good spamming that magic. Oh my god, everyone's down. Not again. Not again. I'm good
I don't even know where I am on the map. I'm just having a good time. That's that's the main important thing
Right, can I get res? cheeky res cheeky res
Wouldn't it be so funny if everyone everyone came up and then I didn't have to raise everyone. Oh my god, please
Ow, don't knock me down. Hold on
Okay, I got one. I got one. I got one. That's the main thing and then I'm flying away
And then the aggro's off of me. I can raise another
Okay, okay. I'll just lay here and no no I'm coming. I'm coming. I'm coming. I'm just trying to get the bears to take the freaking aggro
Oh, thank you
Back in Christmas. Okay. Oh, I think this is good. This is good. This is good. This is good
He's only got a little bit of thingy left. Okay, and there we go. I got poison on him. I got poison on him
Yes
Visit me for animal and we will oh
What what he looks like he runs around healing shit
Oh, I have a new pet. Oh, but but but the sea can you play with something?
I think it's
Oh my god, that doesn't happen
My sea horse is left. I can be your pet sin
Okay, okay. Okay. Yeah, let's go there to match
Oh, I don't have to HP for this. Oh, actually none of us do
so my power sin is uh
I will get you up if you die, but most of the times you have to get me up
We just have to go together
Lie down. Someone throw me. Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no
I'm trying to get him from afar with this magic. Yeah, I'm just trying to stay far
Too dangerous
Okay, I think that's
It for now
Maybe please please be the end of the map. I have literally five HP to my name
And there's no grass to chop to get like fruit from
Oh
What the
Why why am I running into this? Do we have to just go together feel so crooked? Um
Use your shield if you've got one. Oh
Okay
I'm done. No more fights. Please. We need health
Please we're so weak. We need a resupply before we go next. I'm no we've been jumped
I'm not ready for this
Please tell me we get like a billion levels up for this one though
Like I want everyone on the defense on the strength on the magic. Whatever you want this year's
I'm doing this in strut. I'm doing this in strut. Yeah, I've got one sliver of HP. I need to fucking
Just do this in strut spinster
Spinster. Oh someone levels up. You got full health for every level up. You have full health
Because of the level up. I need to keep up
And you're petal live
Wait, we just got literally went off screen. Oh, yeah, you're alive
No, we got reinforcements. Are you serious?
Oh
I cannot tell you how hard I'm biting my lip right now playing this game. I'm like, I'm really invested. I'm like
I can do it. I'm done. It's so hard. I'm down. I'm down
If I can do it
I'll definitely need to give you as a hydration check because it's been playing for a whole second now
Spam the spam the heart beat by the way when you're resin just spam the thingy
It you seem to get more health when you spam it. I thought you had to do it when it hits the heart
Oh, I'm down again. Oh, I'm gonna try the spam thing now. Literally. Yeah, great
Now I'm dead and you get up faster. Yeah
Oh my bro, we can't take anymore. We can't take anymore
Let it be done
And there's going to be like a big ass boss fight. We're about to wallop
And uh, oh, is there a hidden thing in the rocks? No
Oh
Now hold on
Let's just start a rock that you can spank
We go up. Oh my god. I'm claiming
We're claiming. I'm so strong. We're in the Olympics. We're in the Olympics. We're doing rock claiming rock claiming. Oh
Oh, come on bro. Let's take it up
Wait, where the fuck wait
Pink come around the green
Oh
Come on guys
Choppy shop shop. We need we need to get an eyelid. Come on time to get an eyelid together. Are you ready?
Okay
That's right, we play assassins creed out here. We we fucked with the assassins
Okay, let's let's get right
Let's take her time. We'll be super duper safe
smile
So safe
Did anyone get hit? I don't think so. I think we're okay
Okay, it's time
For whatever's in state here. Oh, oh no
I'm ready. It's in my magic. Um, oh
Slimes from the ceiling
Oh my god, they turn into weird slimes
Oh, no no no no no. No, I just have to appreciate the sign this way for the same cloak in
Oh
I'm lagging out. I'm lagging out. I have aggro. What do you mean your aggro is on toggle?
If I sun-cooled then you're the 10
This little random world of warcraft
Oh someone's in the ground someone's been attacked by a slime. I'm getting tracked by a slime. Oh, she's down
She's like I'm the game that gets me. It's the first you tell me and hentai goes down next you tell me a slimes
Got you. I can't believe it
Let's just hug in my face
There is that new alien movie apparently everyone appreciates face huggers more
Like I'm not here at kink shame
Oh
No, they multiply
As long as I thought at first the little tech like the blue blobs that come off of them was them splitting into even smaller stuff
And I'm kind of glad it's not like that
I'm very glad the developers weren't that evil
Because they could have easily done that
Did they even hurt us are they hurting us or are we just killing them that no one's getting damaged
Oh, no, yeah, if they jump on your face
I mean the corksies and bones around us like of course
Do the slimes hurt the dead carcasses looking at us the bones the guts
Brother to the pooping
Wait, do we dive at teabags?
Whoa licked me no way p.r. Peach is done already no licky licky bt. I
Didn't lick it
It seems if you guys have magic it seems to take quite a wall open from my magic. I don't know I
Think I'm magic
I'll get the rest I'll get the rest. Oh, no, I've got a girl. I've got a girl. No, not not not get the rest. I'm getting the rest
Okay, there we go. I'm my magic. I'll try with it. I'll try with the rainbow then. Yeah, fuck you get that rainbow down
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't poop on me
Okay, I'm not into that. Oh
No, no, no, I'm sorry. I'm down to rat. Oh
I mean, he's he's almost half. I mean, this is not a bad attempt considering how
Oh my god, we're getting jumped. Oh
He's almost half, but we're all dying. I know I know we're like literally having to res around each other
And then fight and then resin fight them resin fight them
But I mean it's working. I'm not
Okay, hold on. No, I'm dead. Oh, no, no, no, wait. I think I have our girl. Oh
Yeah, magic is good for him. Yeah, he oh my god. He has a hundred and four on the land
104 on the lake. Oh
My god, get pooped on
Get shout on literally in game
There's just weeks to shit in my panty loons
I mean, I think I'm gonna use there if you can balance the HP honestly. Oh my god, he's sitting on me
I'm dead
Then since comfort oh
My god, the bats are I'm getting up. Oh, I'm getting shout on
Okay, cheeky reds right what reds on peaches? What's right? I'm right. I'm right
Okay, let me get this boy. I can't even move
He has insane that lick is insane. Honestly. I'm spamming. I'm spamming magic
I'm out of magic. I need it to restock
Oh
You got full health you got
I'm spamming. I'm spamming. I'm down. I'm down. I'm down, but
We're doing it. We're doing it. I think we've got it. Oh my god level up on full health get fucked on full health
It's over. Oh, I'm getting I'm getting rolled
Yeah, yeah, oh my god, we did it first time
Visit me for animal
It took us two hours to get this game of click
Okay, take to go now
One more
Yeah, put us in one more chief give us one more with a pet. Let's go read what your pet does
Let's read what your pet does. Oh level up two points
Oh, I should probably put something in defense. Oh shit. Oh
Yeah
I get new magic a power. Oh, holy shit. That's the magic
I'm just going all like literally I don't need defensive. I'm at the back of the map. You know what I'm saying
Maybe I should do something beside defense
You're good next
Strength build. Yeah, strength build for you. I'm going to my leg leg day leg day
Elden ring strength leg day, right? We're going to investigate what sins pet does
What?
I think maybe it might heal like a vampire pet. Yeah, like baseballs like fruits out. That's what I'm thinking
Let's find out. Let's get right into what is my pet?
Oh, look at the enemy power
Chomp's enemy. So you do extra damage. Yeah, you do double rainbow
Oh, you gotta double rumble
What? I need to heal potions up before we go in
Rum knocks down enemies. Oh peaches has an attack one as well
nice
Going strength and faith build
Right, we'll go and buy potions and then we're I'm putting us in for one more chief and then potions potions
Potions
It's health. It's health. We'll get potion
Potions potions
Hepe hepe
Uh, no, not home castle castle keep
Yeah
I thought oh, they still didn't clean up all the corpses like it's it's smelly in here
I'm just gonna spend all my money on this. Oh, literally. I'm spamming on potions is too
I don't know if I can even afford one
Okay, I can afford one two three
All right, that might be me. Wait, that was it me. No, I think that was me
Sorry
Dude, this doesn't happen
x x y
Wait, why can't I get one? Okay, I got one
Why do I hear myself at somebody's?
Um, is it main a speaker? I don't hear any echo. Is it me?
I don't hear anything
Oh, I fit. Oh, I think it's in
I never heard it. It's fine. I have a cleverly field industrial castle
Uh, oh no, 50,000 gold. Oh, Prince. Oh, no, she's crying. Oh, we have to come back with the ladder because she's ugly. Oh
I mean you said it
You are in the beepy enough. Oh wait, we can't he's just laughing at us
Yeah, pretty much
Ha ha ha ha
Okay, I'll hit you with my double rainbow then
I guess we come back later when we have an item
Yeah, yeah
All right, let's do flowery field. Oh
Oh, this is pretty
Oh, we got friends
All right, I actually got
Are we just traveling with the king now?
Over the escort
Over being tapped by bees
Spin spin
Wait, the bees are killing her guys
What they can't defend themselves like a tiny bit question mark
Like they're like, oh, I'm being attacked and dying. I'm going to do nothing about it. Absolutely nothing at all
Oh
Love the beats are so beefy
Who knew mother nature is this pissed
Okay, we're ready, I guess wait, how is the king off the horse now wait sin
You'd knock the king off his own horse and it gave them
It really said the king's a peasant you all walk like us
in me
Okay, it's it's impulse as the queen
As how it should be actually real
The geriatric can walk, okay
Okay, I'm not aware
Okay, okay
Are we like
I got drunk charles for real
I'm getting jumped. I'm getting jumped tonight. RIP that castle pressure
Oh, I suppose I'm just a knight aren't I not a castle crat
That's the night's job. This J makes me feel so overloaded. I feel so
Ah, I need my mana to restore faster
I think I might I've gone a bit. Oh, I put the hill
Oh, but I don't have any more hill
We will protect the princess
Wait, that was all we came here to wait. We go in it. Oh, I'm off. Oh
Wait, how
Were you okay?
I want to get off my horse
Oh
Do the light attack button
For you peaches. Yeah
Oh, wow
Getting guys
the me
We all hail yet
I like how we all get a little cutscene one by one. It's like, oh don't mind us
Oh, wow the delay. Whoa, I picked that perfectly and it was like, yeah, halfway down. I was like, okay, then
Oh, the pet just let oh
Just pinged me over. Oh my god
So we're actually leading our real cuz crusade. We're doing it guys. We're cashing a castle. Wait
Did I start through that? Wait, I was like, I kind of said that right but wrong
The words were so similar
I cannot even see what's happening. I just hope that I'm literally I'm trying to like make some distance
I don't know what's happening. I'm just spamming them double rainbow
Double rainbow all the way across the sky
Yeah
Actually doing good damage
I think cuz they're laid out like we're not missing anything as well. We can't miss when they're like another thing like this
Yeah
Electric I can't steady me some fighting air
I don't know who's still up
I like your pet back going like we and then it just like mols the guy's face off
But it's like so cute. It's like he I'm going in
Literally he's like locking on as someone he's like I'm going in mummy
Shh
Oh my god, they're getting obliterated. Sorry. This is like the easiest when they're like this is oh my god
No, I'm getting obliterated. I'm on hp
Hold on a minute spoke to since
Thank god, you can smell how sweaty I am
You think that you think that you think I don't know
Oh
Did that sound like admiration in your voice you want the big armored one what's going on here? I like a big armored one
I
Please don't like it. Please don't like it. We're doing so well
I'm concentrating like embarrassingly hard on this
We'll finish this I feel dead if we die we die. I'll accept that and then uh, oh
Oh, no, we have to save the wedding one. Come on. We have to have our way crashing this wedding
Hmm
Hydration check
Yeah
Make sure you guys are
I don't want you dying because of this collab. Look. There's a cake with the little
All the guy on it. Yeah
Oh, no, they were forced. It's an arranged marriage. They were forcing them to get married
Not to the one she loves see clearly she loves me because i'm going to destroy you all with my magic when we
Unlock her and then we all fight
Sins only one princess waiting at home. I'll die soon. Oh, okay. Never mind. I'm down
I am dying now. Thank you. I'm dying now
Wait, I can't raise wait. I can't raise. I'm stuck behind you. Hello. I can't get you. Oh, there we go
Peach is level though. Yeah
Hook em up
I
Hit with the pose, please
Oh
Can I have the cherry? I'll be cheeky and have it since i'm so low
Oh, wait, there's food on the tables. Oh, wait, we can't have them. Are you joking me?
There's food to eat that will restore my health and I can't have it
Hey guys a stupid thing, but I can't tell the white and white are that like which of
Oh, you can attack the table
Oh, yeah, it's a lie attack it. I'll the light attack is x and then y is the heavy attack
Oh, thank you
Stony come eat eat. I've got a cookie. I've got a cookie. Okay. Okay
There's a chicken drum. Uh, actually pink should eat. I have potions
Thank you should eat that turkey
Yes, you eat I have potions. I I ate
I eat
I'm not a feeder by the way, but we should eat
Yeah, but but pink should eat anyway
Yes
And then keep eating
Oh, who did the bomb? How did you do that?
I bought a bomb. I don't remember using that
Oh, it's the enemy this but I say enemy's bomb. T is the enemy's bomb walked right into
That's like 10. You guys are getting good
I'm looking electrocuted
Electrically all there's like
Out of all the sound
Oh shit, not as fighting each other by accident
Okay, god, I am building finger muscles using this keyboard. Jesus Christ
They did we break through here. Oh
Nope, there's enemies over there. Oh
Yeah, your bat's fucking them up
I don't really want to level up knock them down ram knock them down. Yes
Yeah
That ram's actually
We're getting so good. I know
I'm like, I don't want to jinx it, but I think this principle might be getting rescued. Oh, they're the first try
Wouldn't that be so totally cool if we could
Oh
I'm trying a new combo smh
She's my head my head my head. Oh new weapon. I don't know. No, I don't want to
Oh, you have a lightsaber. Oh my god, you can have it. It's behind this pillar if you want it. It's literally hiding behind this pillar
Oh wait, I'm risen
No, I'm not. I'm just fighting to the right of you. I'm just fighting to the right of you
Thank you
Ah, right
I can't believe it. I can't believe there's more enemies in the game where you have to kill enemies
I just want that princess. Come on. I want the plunder the booty if you will. There are no riches I need
Oh, I leveled up
Level up
Haha, what happens if I put even more into magic and I just never stopped putting it into magic
The ultimate father
I'm going I'm going in the Guinness World Book of Records in a minute
God, I remember loving those books as a kid. I used to be obsessed with them. I don't know if this happened in uh
For like American schools or whatever
But there used to be a thing called a book fair and like yeah
Yeah, and they would come around and they would show off all these books that you could order in that
But obviously I couldn't get any and but they used to bring the Guinness World Book of Records and we used to all obsess over it
Be like, oh my god. Oh my god. Who are we fighting and what am I fighting the groom?
Oh my god. He's a groomer. Yeah
Discord groomer
He
He plays valorant. Oh my god
She likes us fighting over her
Yeah, she's enjoying it. She's got tears in her eyes, but those are happy tears. She's got tears of literally joy streaming interface
All right, okay avoid the canons. She's dancing
I literally should I'm here for a wedding party
I don't care who I get married to
Give me those things I would use. Oh god. I didn't go to a wedding for years
Hmm, apparently they're really hard to pull off like the there's always like some issue that goes wrong. Wait. Why am I on fire?
Oh my god, he won't stop
Am I missing something?
William
I think I'm yeah, thank you. I'm lacking critical knowledge. I don't know why I'm going on fire when he's on the ground
Oh my god
Holy shit
Princess is
Invisible
For you
No, no, no, it's invincible. Oh, I want to say
All right, all right. Sorry. Sorry shooting at her and as she doesn't
Take any damage
Oh, that was a heavy hit. That was a heavy hit. He's left. I'm gonna die. I'm gonna die avoid the spots
He's invulnerable right now. So we can't actually do anything to him. Oh, shit. That's smoke. This smoke is infer. Oh, I'm
Literally unable to see
Come on come down so we can attack you then you just be playing the organ put all of this on their wedding
This is a bit much. I mean, how did you afford these weaponry?
This is what how I want to know who supplied you because get him that's a good supplier
Right get him
Ow, why are you picking on me?
Right
The strongest one
Oh, I'm not taking aggro because of that
I suppose if that makes sense actually yeah pick on me. I have like tons of potions, please
How are we supposed to avoid it? It's gonna be like covering the whole map in a second
Oh, can I actually hurt this guy? No, you can't hurt him
No, I have no idea where I am. No, I'm I'm I'm guarding my princess. Stop going for me
Stop you're so rude. Honestly. Oh, you did it
Oh, no, you know what this means
Wait, there's another fight. You can take her. What? Oh
Oh, no, he wanted to marry
Wait, no, I'll come on. She was so ours
She was so ours. Are you serious? Oh
Oh, okay, wait, so they're this is it then we get
How many friends are we
Are we fighting each other or is there something we're hitting right? Um, I don't know. I'm just farting. Oh, no, there's enemies
There are enemies
Sorry, if you can't see anything the old methane gas is really
Cover anything. Um, okay. I'm down. I guess
No, I can't see you. You're in the corner
on the platform
Look at this bitch. I'm staring at us
Now she's she's she's not dancing anymore. She's like, oh, no, I might actually no get married to one of you
Yeah, now she understood the gravity of the situation
Mm. Take her long enough
Whoa, what wait, how are we supposed oh my god? I'm spamming I'm spamming magic
Oh, I'm dead. Oh, good. Can you guys spam magic at him long range magic?
If you can
It's all that spicy. Mm-hmm. Hold on. What something's taking
Oh
Hmm
Something keeps jumping up right someone can someone keep attacking can someone attack on the platform and I'll focus my magic
Because I'm I keep getting I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm going
Did we do it? Oh my god. We did it. He's gone. Yeah easy peasy first try. Oh
Oh
Can we have the princess, please? Is there like a secret back here? Sorry just in case. Oh, well close enough. Um, oh
me
You guys eat I think I've still got plenty of potions
There is no way I just want the second princess and we can wrap up
I don't want to take too much time
I always feel bad when like collapse going for too long because I'm like, oh, no, they're gonna be exhausted and like shatter
No
Yeah, I'm I'm okay
As long as it's okay make sure to hydrate though
Again where I didn't hear anyone pick up a bottle of juice. Okay ready
I'm hydrating too. Okay. Okay. I heard that. I heard that. Okay. I believe you
proof
Well, I was hydrating on my wine. So that's why I'm dead. Are you drinking wine?
Oh my god. Yep. I didn't trust myself to drink
I have a very high alcohol tolerance
Hmm
I'm good proof. She's a real hag. We love hag v-tubers out here shadow wizard and money gang
Wait, who's making is that sins mate?
Hmm, what does your best do?
Wait, no, wait, wait. Where's my pickle?
Where's my pet?
I think he's attacking someone. All right
Okay, come
I'm coming. Looks like the first one. Yep. Uh, who do you think mom? How do you lose?
Let's show my bat's gone
But I'm still here
I gotta have pink though. Oh, I need that back. Anyway, bro. This is too much one of them's got a bomb
One of them's a bomb producer. Oh, I don't like the bomb
Oh, I'm getting ruled
Do you make them do a peace sign? I swear the enemies just did a peace sign because of your stuff pink
I think that maybe might be the new effect of your thing
Hmm
The enemies did a peace sign when you did your thing him up. Oh, oh
Hold on. I can't even
What is that noise? I think
Oh, it's the loot goblin making the noise. I just assumed it was sin making a really fun one. I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry. I just I don't know what I just did your make you like cutting out whilst you were giggling. Oh your pet's back
Okay, now I can
Oh, what the fuck right there 100. What does your pet does then?
My pet's back besides going away and coming back
I think it disappears after he gets a kill. Maybe he like has to go away and digest this food and then he comes back
He's like, okay, let's look. Okay. It's a loot goblin. Yeah. Okay that
Oh, no, it's me. It's me by the way
It's me by the way cut this machine
Can't maybe you can do this. Oh, there's food in it. Yeah. Yeah, thanks
Don't mind if I do
Even though I only have one potion left. I should actually take a little bit more seriously, but
Oh my god, I cannot melee at all. There's like no damage in my melee whatsoever. I'll thank him. I might
Oh, wait, what what happened? I'm still led
I'm still led though. Wait, what are you? It was good. No, you can't rest now
No, no, it's it. No, no, you can you can it's a visual glitch or something. They like
I don't know why maybe you just that's gonna try that. Oh, okay
Sin method time sin method
Come on. Oh, thank you
Sin
Okay, there we go
I am just spinning to win right now. I don't know what I'm doing. Give us that second princess
Because I don't want to do anything else between
Doing better than me
What
Critical see I feel like we never get critical hits. I don't know how to upgrade like to get there are critical hits
Yeah, they're so rare. Literally they hardly show up at all
Oh, this is like a boss fight. Well, uh, well, it's been a good stream. Thanks everyone. Huh
Okay
Oh, there must be a loot goblin in your backpack
Oh, okay, okay then
Oh for fuck's sake. I went in the lava
Ah
Okay, surely oh we
Oh the teeth the teeth the teeth on the teeth. Okay
Our bad. Our bad. We need to put our glasses on. Tee hee should have gone speck savers. Tee hee
Bro, why am I all the way up in the sky? I'm not gonna strut us here. Oh
Oh, well, I felt like we were actually going into a pub for a second there. I got excited. I was like, oh, I'm putting my order in
That would be nice. Well, then
I'll take a cheeky a apple juice. I thought he saw the toilet because he was trading the paper
Oh my god, can my mana come back faster, please
No, no, it's fine. It doesn't bother me at all that it takes half an hour for me to do one attack. No, I'm sure
I'm not a detriment to my teammates at all. I'm sorry. There's so much
No, no, no, no, no, it's cuz it's cuz we're keep going into the next level without resupplying
Because I don't actually know when the next level starts. We're just like keep going forward
I don't even have money though. Look how much money features guys
Don't need to stack it
You can deposit them for that
Well
I'm just glad I'm not dying. I think I finally mastered it. Oh, good for you
Oh, yeah, I really like you
Are you? Wait, is anyone done? No
Poison come on poison come on poison one pound
It's just british memes similar. That's right. You're gonna get the ball English memes, you know
Oh
My for as much as my whale is like coming out of my money. It's not really
I wouldn't say it's having like a massive effect on
How do I have solitude? Oh, I'm down. Oh, I'm a dumb dumb. I've not got any potions left. Uh, it's all on you guys have fun
Turn back
Oh cheeky revive don't mind me spend to my own spend run
Cheeky bit of poison. I'm not really doing anything. So I might as well just revive
No, no, no, because you level up every time like we like kill stuff. Well, you see like oh, that's me the level up
Well at the point still stands you level up every time we kill a new enemy and you do damage
Okay, right
I'm positive attitude while being dead apparently
My god, it's never just your presence is helping us feel
Comfort in our battles to find the prince. Oh, come on
Bro, let's get the second princess and wrap it up. Come on. Wrap it up
Come on
We'll do a little fight and whoever wins
Sin has one princess to her name. Sure. We can't we can't allow her a second
Wait, I might wait. I got a princess. Wait, what did you know when the princess fight? Oh, no
It was peaches. That was right. It was peaches because you freaking stunlock me peaches. Don't think I'll forget that
I'll be I'm I'm gonna be blinding you in valorant. I'm I'm seeing that right now
I'm gonna purposely blind you in valorant when you swing a corner
How about for the princess? Oh my god. Oh my yes. Oh my yes
Wow, did I even get you up? I didn't
Oh
I can't okay. I'm coming. I'm coming. What? Oh my god. Is everyone dead but me? I'm not coming
Bruh, I do not have the
I've never raised harder in my life. I don't know if you okay. And now oh no, okay
It's a bit of a situation when you get raised but a situation on the less is better than imminent death
So, uh, yes, I'm trying
Oh, fuck up. Oh, please. Oh, fuck. Oh, no. No, come on. The freaking lag doesn't register
I like start dancing on your corpse like come on
I'm like start a motin like excuse me. We're in fortnight. No, get me off. Get me off. Hold on
I'm playing fortnight
No, stop. No, no, right. I'm needing right and hold on. I can do this. I can do this
I am a good gamer. I'm so mlg right. I've got one ally
That's why I need one teammate off and then I'll go for sin because this guy's over here
and then we'll get
pink
and then
and then we'll win
And then we never wait. Where am I? I'm lost. Okay. I don't get pink
I get I get oh my god. Please. Please just register
Holy oh so much so much health. Wow
I know
And a noose whip it. No, I don't want a lightsaber, please. I need all the magic in the world
Oh, I don't know what that lightsaber is. I need the defense scissors
We're so ready for the boss. We're so ready. Oh, he's crying
How the fuck is he though? He's not the groom. Whoa
Is he the secret lover as I thought?
Maybe
Oh my god. Whoa, the turn already. Oh my god. Razor is there. Oh my god
Oh my god. What the fuck am I doing?
I'm sorry. I'm out. I'm out. I'm out. Okay. Okay. It's magic
Let's do cheeky magic
Oh, fuck me
Okay, oh, he doesn't seem to take poison damage. So this is literally my worst matchup possible. I was not really work
Did anything work on him or is this melee sins the strongest melee wise out of all of us so
This might be a sin boss fight unironically. Okay. Well, I died but I got to enough
I did my I did my job. I did what I had to do. Oh god. I need your shield more. No, no
No, no, no, no right. It pinks off to the right of the screen. Oh no. Oh my god. Oh my god. Peaches
It's on peaches. No
No, no, that's fine. Oh my god, you have six level up points. No, we can do this. Sorry. We can do
I'm you're you're being held hostage. We can do this level up. Okay. You're all being held hostage. We can so do this
Oh, the magic
I'm maxing out. What did that happen?
right trigger a
um
The your lack of death perception will be the end of you real
That's it. Oh god. Oh
I don't know
Oh, you've missing one. I got another one. There you go
Right, fuck it. Right easy easy peasy lemon squeezy can do this. Oh, no potions. Damn it. Right, right. Hold on
Wait, hold on. Hold on. Hold on potions right straight out there
Literally, they're all like ready and they're like, huh? Did you guys just see that enemy there? And I was like, no
No, no enemy all
Okay, let's go all the way back. Do do do do do do. Oh, no not that one
Do do do do do to the castle keep right and then we'll buy what we can
Okay, I will buy the potion
Put some portion on it. Oh wait
I literally was thinking that as well
Or I guess the hose again
That movie was uh
Mm-hmm
Wait, don't not
Oh, I think we can only buy one at a time. Okay. Okay, that makes sense. Yeah
There's a gold poop if you want I think
Gold poop. Yeah, they're named by two potions. Oh, I can afford two potions again
Living life of luxury
All right, I'm uh, just oh you're only like five potions at a time
Oh
I can't potion max. Wow. I can't abuse the mechanics of this game. I can't believe that shocking
Absolutely shocking right no more holding us hostage because we're easy peasy going to do go up. Thank you
Um, yes. Yes. Yes. Keep going. Keep going. Keep going. Keep going me
Right keep going
Okay easy right we'll play super safe. We know what's coming up. There's a lot of enemies some of them come from the same
Yes, no, I literally
V shipper holds others hostage just to complete her game
Just so she can get a princess
Okay, nice and easy. We'll take it take it easy. I'll grab that
Oh, I'm just not gonna get walloped
Oh
It's all coming together it's all coming together
I
Next this is actually a really good game. I'm actually really I'm surprised how much I enjoyed it. Um, I saw some footage and I was like
I still enjoy it. Yeah, like I'm just right now
We're focusing up. It's happening. I just have a flight hack and slash honestly
No, you don't it's not your game type. What is your game type?
Uh
strategy games
I saw you play boulders gate actually all three of yous were on boulders gate shagging it
Yeah, like
I had to play if you do some strategy, so main piece you would just get naked and pinks like, okay
We're going here next up to them next and like piece. Just like look at my boo
That's lovely. Yeah
And her is the only one that can romance a starry and I'm actually raging about them
How does the multiplayer work in that game? Do you have your own character or?
Oh my god, I'll play the you can play the the original character who made your own. Oh, okay
Uh, I think I think I'm in any games kind of category as long as it's not hard then I'm fine
Oh my god, I can blast off with a far. Oh, I'm blasting off again
It won't stop
That's terrible. How old am I literally a five year old child? Tee hee farts are funny
Farts are deadly in this game. Oh
A bit too potent and
Right pink. I'm gonna get you to hold back so because I have more potions than you so you do magic from afar
And then that way
Yes, ma'am some aggro and then you
Shouldn't need to use your potion until we get to the boss fight
After the boss fight, I don't know what happens. We'll we'll try our best doesn't it?
Okay
Actual strategies actual strategies and a 10 year old game. Yes, real true
It's done you're old
I think uh since it it was like
Okay, it's not even that old when I think about it
Okay, I'm spam. Are we good or someone got lightsaber
You're staying with scissors
Hey, if it's got high defense, so it's definitely yeah, that's best for me. Okay boss fight this time
We have a much better chance out at ease. I'm so over this guy
Actually
He goes straight for it. Never let me thought I think for a second
Okay, okay, I'll do 28 per hit that's good
28 per hit that's all I need
You can use your shield when he just throws those daggers you can use your shield. That's really
Like
I'm missing depth perception depth perception check roll for depth perception. I roll the one I roll the one
It's over
No shield the other way. Yeah, I have I have no depth perception either
I literally like I keep throwing my long range magic and it's like miss miss miss and I'm like, okay
I get it. I get it. Just can I have an auto lock then when I get to like level
No way I went I almost went down because of that. Well, where is he? Who's he going for?
Come on. Right. We're almost
Okay, yes, I have used a potion. That's fine. I don't know if I got lightsaber. I think I accident. Oh my god
Oh, you didn't notice you picked it up by accident
I don't know what it's like abilities are if it ups your strength or something
Is that his grave to the right? Are we about to put him in his own grave?
Oh
No, no, no, no. Is that a new move? Oh, he's going for pink. Jeez. He hates you
He's not gonna dump that on her. Oh, literally
He can smell the weak link. Oh, no
Oh, that was a big hit. I don't know who did that. Oh, no
Bruh, he wants you
He wants you
Oh
Oh, he's one. He's one if you want to get aggressive. He's one
If you want to kill, here we go. Oh, he does go into the grave
Called it called it called it. Oh
All right, let me remember a little bit
Oh, that's a reference to that
Okay, let's
Yeah
We did it. We got the second princess
Wait, the gems are only worth one
We're gonna read that one. That's a scam. Okay. You ready to fight each other to the death
Look at how healthy I am. Okay. Oh, here we go. Here we go
Wait, we didn't let you have like, um
They don't let everyone heal up
At least make it fair. Jeez
Are you guys prove it? Mayhaps you guys are weak to magic. That would be lovely. That'd be great
If you guys could be weak to magic. Thank you. Yes, please
I'm getting my ass beat and get my ass beat
I repeat ass beat. I repeat ass beat
You stay away from me
Oh my god, no, she's my princess
She's mine. Get fired on get fired on get fired on get fired on get fired on
Get fired on get fired on
No, no pink. Don't you dare. Don't you dare pink? Don't you dare?
No, it's center pink. It's center pink. It's center pink
I wonder who it will be
You cheeky
Oh
Watch it. Oh my god, we have to sit in the chair
I can't believe it shaking my head my head. Oh watch it
You're arena unlock. No, we're not fighting. I'm happy to wrap up. That was a fucking kidding. Oh, I want to thank you guys
Because I suck
That was strong
Without you getting stomped when we went to Pellum. So you took the aggro. That's
It's very important to take aggro to let your teammate you enabled us
For the dub you enabled us team work. Thanks the dream work. Oh my god, you guys. Thanks
Right. I'm not gonna force you to do it anymore. I promise. I promise. Okay. Um, he says it's a bad thing
I love this game. What the fuck a bro?
Can we take a pee break a pee break? Oh, I was gonna wrap up. That's me. Oh
Yeah, I'm not gonna that's like three. What two and a half months rid of us
No, I don't like asking for more than two hours from streamers. I think it's a bit too much to be honest
And I was like, uh, yeah, no
I'll wait for the pee break. Yes, right. You better hold it baby girl. That's right. Hold it. That's my face
All that wine in your bladder. Um the way your body's processing that alcohol through your liver. Um, that's getting to me
Okay, calm down
Right, I I'm gonna say a super duper special
Thank you to everyone who showed up if you would like to
Cheekily sign off and then I'll jump out the discord. So please pollug yourself. Not literally though
Uh, oh sin just left the call
Oh, okay. Well, there you go. Oh
Okay
Uh, well, thank you for having me. I had a wonderful time
And and and and it was nice to hang out with you and and I hope we can do it again soon
I don't I don't really know how to plug myself, but hi. I'm peaches and I'm shit at this game, but I'm
Generally chill. So if you want to come over then I'll have you and and and thank you. What happened to me?
Thank you
Thank you very much for inviting me today
Lots of fun, even though I sucked
Thank you for carrying my ass
If you would like to listen to some ASMR or more
Cheeto roleplay
strategy games
streams then
Hey
Baby pink vt. Thank you
Slash baby pink vt. I will update the link in the description so you can check everyone out with ease peaches also does a smart
I will link to that as well
Sin I will link to sins twitch
And I will say a special. Thank you for everyone. I'm really appreciative. Thank you for
Making time in your humble day to play castle crushers with me. I'm very thankful
Okay, we'll get great. Thank you. I'ma leave now. Love you. Bye
Love you
We did it see now I can see them on vtub studio
Look at all of them. It's my favorite part of stream where I can see their vtuber model still pop up
Well, we've lost one. Well, we've lost two
Hi
And again, I did not expect to enjoy that game so much
It was so good. I'm sorry. I've really really enjoyed that. I really enjoyed that
Uh, I thought I'll eat look at things that you've been doing come up come up right now. Oh, she had her
Oh, she had her thing that whole time
I think oh
She's taking the asset off to prepare for her next stream next time she streams. Well, see you doing pink. Come on
Let's see
I love no
Okay, I wonder what was that that game was surprisingly fun. Please don't be surprised if I make that stream snipe game
I
Thoroughly
Enjoyed that I
Thoroughly enjoyed that. Oh my god. It's me and pink
Should be sweating should be like
Don't be a crew. No, it's my favorite part
That was so fun. I did not expect to enjoy that game. Uh, don't get me wrong
We were getting our ass beat but like once it started clicking and like obviously once you level up with the magic and stuff
Hmm, it was so good. How long did you sleep? Oh, I slept so long
I guess slept like six seven hours. I've been doing a few behind the scenes skills for the babies
Um
I
Said uh, did you process vivi my eyes are still puffy from vivi. It's literally that bad
Someone's still in game with me. I don't know who you know what I'll I can figure out by taking us to the keep who is in game with me
Oh, it's pink. She's not shut down our game yet
Um
Yeah, don't be surprised if this turns into a stream snipe thing
But you'd be playing the game off collab
We're do stream snipe we're refunds
Sin took the most op night, but miss killed someone. I mean that genuinely that was the first time all four of us have experienced that game
Uh, I don't ever recall mummy. I see you woke up early yesterday. Yeah
Oh, wait, no, I would have got seven hours if I didn't wake up early, but had to wake up early. So I got five hours
Yeah
What is the thing I can literally a mental block due to vivi brah I was like crying right in ASMR scripts
I was like
And then I put I brushed my fingers through your hair jet
Like that
dealing with it
um
I haven't watched vivi don't spoil it
You're feeling brave
Really
Uh, looks like he's just like sitting farm the wheel
My needle way
Um
Yeah, I did not expect to enjoy castle crashes that much. That's a a thoroughly fantastic game
I don't know if there's
If it's possible. I just I feel like peaches and pink. It's not their kind of game
So I wouldn't ask them to play it again. Um
But if we got two out of the four princesses, I mean technically we're already like 50 percent of the way there
All right, so I'm like covering up the gameplay. No, that there's much gameplay. I'm just rambling while doing stuff in game
But yeah, I'm not gonna I won't ask them to
play and
But this was really this was surprisingly a really nice find. Uh, I really thoroughly enjoyed that. I mean
The green brap night, bro. My farts are devious
absolutely devious
If there's a sudden influx of emotional strips, we'll know why he um she bees ASMR went up as well and acs if you haven't seen it yet
um
I
Well, I've got a membership stream after this. Uh, where I'm drawing your profile pictures, but I'm not sure
You didn't get the information what information?
Mommy's braps are worse than muster guests now steady on now steady on now
Um
But yeah
I don't know what the agendination is with the membership are used
So I wanted to do you know what fuck it will discuss it in the membership stream before
You know what? Um, I'm out of milk. I have terrible news about milk. So I can't do anything. Um, thank you again. She be in here
I'm for the rude. I'm going the need to redirect. Oh, she bees up on faith
Oh, I can return the favor. She's up on faith right now. Okay
Yeah, you got your deliveries as well. I got my collar. I got my lego set life is good
It's why I love this game a lot. You enjoy it alongside the lobo. It's so cute
Um, I thought I was sending that text
Center text real
Um, right what I'm going to do. I'm going to redirect into she be any sheepsters. Um
Oh, right, okay. Um
I'm
Preparing ink right now. Well, that's the file. This is a milk substitute, but literally I'm so sad
I was like, I can't even have my cup of tea in the morning. Absolutely shattered
My collar. Well, there's two collars. There's one with your name on it and one with my name on it, say
The question is who wants to be on the end of the league? That's terrible, bro
I was laughing my ass off when pink was like, that's too far and I was like, you're right. It's too far and I'm going to keep pushing it
Uh, um, as you can know, I'm surprised for us. Uh, peaches pink and sin very very good people
Love them. They're gorgeous. I kiss them. I make out with them
I do some other things with them. Maybe perhaps may have
For for mommy and it were the least for us. Okay. I am going to redirect into she be
I'm going to thank you so so much for watching the collab as always when it comes to collapse
I do apologize for the little chat interaction that there is
um, because
Um, you know how it is, you know how it be, but it was very nice to hang
with um
Some other creators, um
Obviously, I'm rather on the shy side of collabing. I've been pushing myself to do a few things
Um, I know you're probably your eyes are rolling out your skull at the thought of a valouring collab
But I thought
It would be nice to do to be taught how to play valourant by valourant players
But I was like, so what rank are you peaches and she was like
Uh, did she say bro? I think she said bronze and I was like
bronze
Who am I getting taught by
I love peaches so much. She's so cute. She said silver. I think she went silver in the past. I think she went bronze
Uh being that would actually be a really funny play learning learning valourant from bronze players
That would be so cute. Hold on doing a tweet right now. Hey, are you guys shit at valourant?
I'd like to collab with you. You're gonna teach me how to play
Um
I'll watch mommy play anything even if it's valourant even I get to do the discord
That a predator voicing
Then the mic
But yeah, no, I had so much fun on that game. Don't be surprised if there's a come stream snipe me of this
And it'll maybe be like I'll swap you though
I don't want to say every map the maps aren't really that big
I didn't realize how much progress we were making. We were like hauling ass like we got stuck at that one bit
But as soon as it started clicking we were off on one
um
Uh climbing and league and valourant is very different to overwatch out
To be honest when people say valourant or league for the meme, but don't really hate idea valourant eat it in stream
Yeah, I'm dating you right now
Oh my god, you go did they have play of the game in valourant?
What did what did they do in valourant?
What happens in there? I always got told it was like cs go and overwatch kissed
So I like is there play of the game in valourant or no?
There's a new dlc coming out for castle crashes. Yeah, apparently there was uh, oh my god
The failures I couldn't do it. Oh my god. Oh, they're players of lift
rip
It's like cs go webbillies. Okay via valourant is counter strike, but hero shooter
Good luck with the learning. No, I'll be like one stream and then that's a wrap it up one stream and then we'll wrap it up
I'm not fucking I turn in in a valourant streamer and turn in an overwatch streamer and turn in a league streamer wrap it up
Wrap it up
wrap it up
right now
Um
Did you see that balochro is coming to phones this month like the game?
The balochro person's been doing fantastic. I'm really happy. Well, I'm
I'm really happy for him. Um, just because like
Honestly, I would be such bra. I'm getting off my damn phone
You see that and then you get addicted. I think pink was a little bit disappointed that you ended stream so early so I
I never want to ask for more than two hours. Um
I do not want to ask for more than two hours and um
I think peaches was struggling to enjoy it, which is
Understandable. It was the first time and I didn't want to I don't want anyone to be miserable collabing with me
And I think this is you know, two and a half hours
Um
Concord stream when doesn't that game just die?
Is that bad? I'm genuinely excited for part two of overwatch. No, probably not. I just like being goofy. Okay
It's like being a goofy book
Right. My arse is gonna end redirecting to sheepsters and then give me five minutes and I'll prepare for my stream
Uh my membership stream
Uh, so yes t minus five minutes on a membership stream
And if not, I'll see you tomorrow because the agenda nation for tomorrow is drum roll
Wait to have a drum roll. Hold on. Have a drum roll
And it doesn't work, but of course it will. Uh, hold on. Hold on bear with me
AC's in the room bear with me. What's it called a stream deck?
Stream deck, please open
Uh drum roll tomorrow's agenda is
The ring fit and shower stream
Yay
Ring fit ASMR. I don't know how I'm gonna do that one
I have no idea how I'm going to exercise quietly and that ASMR mic
Uh, but we'll get we'll figure it out. Okay, we'll figure it out
Um, okay. Thank you so so much. I will see you tomorrow or I'll see you in five minutes. Either way, I'll see you
Maybe throw a window as well. I don't know it'll happen. Okay. I love you. Bye. I'm sorry
I'm a bit scatterbrained at the minute because I had to wake up rather rather early
And I didn't get my caffeine hit with my cup of tea shot behavior, but I see please say hi to she before me. Bye. Bye